Four,
three,
two,
one.
Mr Paige,
how are you?
I never had a bad day in my life.
Ever elevated.
Plenty of bad moments.
Moments.
But you recovered.
Yeah.
You know,
um,
to me it's all your state of mind
period.
And I don't stay there.
If I go down,
I get back up.
If you're going to chew that pump,
we're going to go fucking crazy.
Well,
one of those in my mouth the other day,
like 150 comments because rope.
Well I got,
I got the throat coat.
Yeah.
Um,
listen man.
First of all,
I love what you're doing.
I really do.
I think it's fantastic and I'm a big fan
of yoga and what you've done for not
just what you've done is made yoga
available to people that thought that
yoga was for chicks.
I and I,
I don't now.
It's funny you say that because how it
started,
it was yoga for regular.
It was regular people,
regular guys made it for guys.
People think of yoga as being something
that like you have to be into,
you know,
you gotta be all day and you hear Dallas
diamond page.
What the fuck or Diamond Dallas page
you,
how you know you're this giant pro
wrestler guy,
like you're in a yoga and you're really,
really into it.
I mean you've got your own system of
yoga.
I mean this is for,
for something that I think is very
important for body maintenance and for
keeping your spine healthy and mobility,
which is one of the things that a lot of
us ignore,
especially big guys who liked to lift
weights or do a lot of crazy.
Gosh,
Daniella,
I'm,
I'm the guy who wouldn't be caught dead
doing yoga the first 42 years of my
life,
but I didn't start wrestling.
I was 35 really,
really,
and my career didn't take off.
The was Ford.
How old are you now?
Sixty two.
Dude.
If you folks saw what he did with no
warmup,
no warm up,
Ben Dover,
grab your ankles fully,
fully flattened your body out.
Press your body up against your thighs
with no warmup.
Then he picks his knee,
his ankle up and fully extends his leg
over his head.
I mean that.
That is incredibly impressive for a 20
year old person.
It's all about staying ahead of it,
you know,
it's all about owning it.
I'm going back to just my career.
I mean my crew took off in [inaudible]
96,
which was I was 40 years old,
97 and 98 and I was on top of the world
wrestling 270 days a year every year.
And then I did the tonight show,
Hollywood squares,
a movie called the first daughter was my
first movie.
I did.
So I mean I was probably working 320
days a year and the wear and tear on
your body after awhile,
like boom,
I took a power slam from Laura power
bomb from Kevin Nash.
Kevin's legit six,
long way down and it wasn't that bump
that blew my back out.
It was all of it and being almost 43
years old and when I ruptured my l four
and l five and we have this amazing
vertebrae,
that is what allows us to do all this
crazy shit that we do but really allows
us is those shock absorbers are
absorbers those discs in between the
vertebrae.
We'll think of a jelly donut and slap
that Jelly donut.
And now there's nothing there.
So I have no desks in between my l four
or l five.
I was told by three different spine
specialists.
You're never going to wrestle again.
I just signed a multimillion dollar
three year deal.
So the guy who wouldn't be caught dead
doing yoga would do anything to get back
into a ring.
And I was married at the time and uh,
she kind of bullied me into it and once
I started doing a job,
just like,
you know,
I start filled difference and I thought
it'd thinking,
Wow,
now did you talk to any doctors that
wanted to replace your discs,
are fused your disks to one of the fuse
and one didn't.
And his thing was this a 1999.
So the beginning of those spacers that
they have now don't have anything discs
and have any of that.
And his whole thing was,
if we do fuse you and you go back,
you will be crippled because you won't
recover from that.
So again,
going to do yoga.
And I started doing Bryan kest.
Have you ever taken more Brian Class
classes are in la?
No,
he's amazing.
He went to yoga as a power yoga.
He's the guy who kind of put power yoga
on the map and he made me feel like,
okay,
that dude's cool.
Like,
and then today's a buddy of mine,
you know,
uh,
but at the time I was just doing as vhs
tapes,
but for what I wanted,
it wasn't getting me everything.
So what I did,
I've rehabbed both shoulder surgeries,
both knee surgeries,
and I'm Kinda like God given gifts of
figuring out how to heal myself.
I'm the first guy in professional
wrestling to ever ice isis body by
almost a decade,
eight years before they would start
doing that.
Do you mean like ice baths?
Like your shoulders back,
inflammation,
take it down.
I just got that.
How'd you figure that out?
Um,
you know,
just different reading on different know
people had,
how they healed themselves and what
people were saying.
And what I've found that a lot of people
don't want to put the extra work and
they can be the hardest workers ever,
but they won't go that extra mile just
to go get a bag of ice,
fill it up,
put it on your knees,
put an ace bandage around it.
You can go wherever you want.
Although it's also like part of the
culture of tough guys.
They don't give a fuck,
right?
Just go get a beer and have some food.
Right?
Just exhausted.
There's a little bit of that,
right?
There's something about the same type of
God.
It's so tough.
They can work 300 days a year.
It was also the same type of guy that's
going to go out and just deal with it.
And Steve Means Austin.
When I broke in,
I was like 35 and a half.
He's 26 and Austin was always way ahead
of the curve as far as talent.
But he wouldn't know.
He wouldn't.
He was like,
what are,
you know?
And cared.
Leah got those ice bags.
So back then we were drinking beers.
Not that it's right to do,
but back then we were,
and he would put the beers on my ice
bags in between my,
uh,
my ace bandage.
Just keep us beers cold.
A true story.
It's her story.
So,
you know,
the bottom line is I started to mix the
rehabilitation techniques with the yoga
positions.
Then I threw an old school calisthenics,
pushups,
squats,
crunches,
and I did them with the slow burn
movement because I had to.
And in the beginning I had to do them on
my knees.
So when you say slow burn movement,
this is what you were just shown me that
before we started the podcast,
a lot of dynamic tension exercise.
Exactly.
Which,
a lot of it,
Bruce Lee was into exactly what a lot of
that stuff.
Go look at Bruce Lee.
Did he ever have an ounce of fat on him?
The guy was shredded,
but yeah,
that whole time under tension thing,
something I call dynamic resistance.
I hated that.
And like for the pushups,
you know,
I would lower for three,
hold three inches off the ground for
three charter ranga,
come up for three,
lower for three,
hold for three,
then I'd go into Cobra in downdog and in
the beginning I had to do,
I'm on my knees,
but then I built that strength to get
off my knees.
And then three second pushups became
five,
five became 10,
10 became sets of 10.
If you go to my DDP Yoga,
facebook,
you'll see a video up there of me doing
all my 62nd birthday.
Well actually two days after 10,
ten second pushups at 62.
So my core strength is at a different
level.
I don't lift weights anymore.
I haven't really for 10 years because I
really don't need it and I don't need
the size.
I like being like 2:30.
The bottom line is what today is called
unbranding DDP.
Why?
Because I want people to stop calling
it.
Just yoga because it's so different now.
You've done a lot of yoga?
Yeah.
What you do,
I just took you through in that minute
and a half.
Is that like anything you've ever done
in a yoga studio now?
It's very different.
You what you were saying,
your dynamic tension thing definitely
adds another element to it.
And then I have fun with it,
man.
I got you.
I do shit like when you take your
endorse a lunge and you throw your arms
up.
I go superstar,
you know,
when we're,
when we're in a like a lunch or folding
folding were to explode into touchdown.
I'd say throw a little rick flare on the
end of that.
And is everybody explodes?
Just having people having fun.
I,
I did,
um,
a big event.
That was this weekend.
It was called all in and it's a um,
cody Rhodes who's,
uh,
the American dream,
dusty Rhodes son,
he's been in independent wrestling.
He was at the show,
wwe for 10 years.
And bottom line is he went away.
They left their guaranteed money,
that'd be like a half a million bucks,
left it and went to follow the dream
because he knew he was a main event guy
and him in these kids,
the young bucks they sold out.
This arena was 10,426 people in 29
minutes and 36 seconds to counted the
cow the second that'll they did because
it's a really big deal when you forget.
So out when you're an independent group,
you're not the wwe now.
That's insane.
It's insane how many different groups
are there now?
There's Nwa was wwe,
right?
There's Roy h,
there's the row as my buddy booker t
calls had down there in Houston and was
with billy.
Billy Corgan owns right now.
I'll tell you what the smell.
That's the batch.
Cody was going for the Nwa championship
against Nick who was just one of the
stuff,
studs up our business and um,
he uh,
that a hell of a match.
And uh,
Billy owns that title.
Now think about this Vince Mcmahon,
just just,
I want to say he was paid one point $2
billion by Fox for the programming for a
live show on Friday nights.
I'm not sure what the deal is at six
years or eight years,
but one point 2 billion and then I heard
there's another multibillion dollar
contract being out there,
comcast or something.
So that's like nfl stuff.
So when that kind of attention comes to
wrestling,
more people are going to be like,
Ooh,
I want to get involved in that.
And plus Vince really has taken it
mainstream and a different level.
Like back when we were killing it in the
nineties.
I mean we had the highest rated show on
cable television,
whether it was wcw or wwe APP.
Every week we are one,
two and three,
sometimes one,
two,
three and four.
Top four shows.
But our dollars that we could get for
the advertising was nothing like they're
getting today because they made it kid
friendly.
They changed that.
And it was brilliant by Vince,
you know,
uh,
it really,
it changed format.
But today it's about to go through
another boom and this whole independent
thing that cody and these young bucks
who are great kids,
uh,
did,
it really lit up that world.
And it's the same thing all over the
country.
I'm interested a world Japan's really
big right now.
And so is,
uh,
so is.
I'm a UK and Mexico.
The really,
really big.
One of the guys from the UFC,
mathew riddle just got signed to the
wwe.
He was heard that.
Yeah,
his story,
his camp,
it's kind of fucked up.
He got fired from the UFC for failing a
pot test.
And the crazy thing,
it's so crazy.
He left the guy smile.
She's right.
It's even more crazy that,
you know,
now it's legal right now.
Pot's legal and now the Numb,
the level that you can get tested for is
so much lower than anything that he got.
But I,
he enjoys it.
I don't think he's missing fighting.
You know,
fighting is.
I know that pro wrestling is probably
harder on your body doing those 300 days
a year.
I mean,
I don't think there's anything like it
in all of entertainment.
I really don't.
I mean it's,
it's crazy to think that you are getting
body slammed and thrown into the ropes
and forearm slammed and all that shit's
going on 300 days a year.
It's really,
it really.
It's not fair.
Just really should be a way where you
could take some time off.
It doesn't make any sense.
When I was on Hollywood squares one time
so much.
So once your season,
when are you?
Nothing about wrestling.
I said Hilarious when I'm hurt,
you know,
but you know,
the bottom line not hurt,
injured,
injured ligaments like.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
You guys compete or perform hurt on a
regular basis.
I mean,
and so did the guys in the NFL,
so the guys in the UFC as well?
Absolutely.
I think with Matt Riddle,
it's like he's got a great personality
and you know,
it doesn't have to cut any weight
anymore and now he's gigantic and he's a
fun guy.
I think wwe is perfect for someone like
me.
I was down there.
I train a lot of the guys down to neck,
it's called nxt next and that's a.
These kids are unbelievable.
They're so talented,
but I bring my ddpy program down to them
and they're all on my hands.
So you're starting that early with these
guys.
So they plus I'm like,
you know,
again,
I'm 62,
their 24 to 28,
you know,
so they grew up watching me so it's much
easier for,
for me to get them to pay attention to
do is look at Chris Jericho,
he's one of the top stars in the world
and he is not with wwe right now.
He,
you know,
he comes and goes and he was at that
show all in.
He did a run in a surprise thing.
It blew the roof off.
He's going to be 48 in November.
He wrestles like he's 28.
He's been doing my program since he did
the same thing I did when he blew his
back out.
And three Dr said he was not going to
rustle anymore.
Five weeks later,
85 percent pain free,
three months later he headlined
Wrestlemania against Punk.
He talks about it all the time now.
How has your back today,
those same disks,
if I don't do it,
it's kind of like brushing your teeth.
You gotta brush your teeth.
I don't have to do it every single day,
but pretty much,
you know,
and when I wake up I might first 10
minutes,
why call it wake up man,
I feel I call it oil for the tin man and
woman.
And the real proof of this for me
because I'm the first transformation.
The bottom line is they said my career
was over when I was 42.
I started doing what now is called DDP.
Why three months,
less than three months later,
joy.
I was back in the ring at 42.
They said my career's over 43 on the
world champ.
And that's like getting our ads are
Oscar.
You know what I mean?
It's like you're the guy,
you deserve this.
When I yield the most eyes on you,
you know I was.
I was in a match with Hogan flair in
staying three.
Arguably.
Maybe he'll eat in the top five biggest
names ever.
And I walk out that world champion Ric
Flair,
took the diamond cutter in the middle.
It was Hogan.
Hogan gave me such a hug afterwards
like,
this is what this business supposed to
be.
That someone like you who known would
believe would ever be anyone could work
so hard that they would become the world
champ.
When I got my hall of fame ring a 2017
inside ahead.
Inscribed in here.
Work ethic equals dreams.
Explanation Point,
DDP.
And that's what it is.
You know,
I don't tell you anything.
You understand.
Putting the work in,
putting the work in is everything.
Now you're back to date.
Did you ever get an Mri on it?
Oh yeah,
I did all that well,
but now,
now no know I don't have any.
I don't.
If I don't do it,
if I'm on too many planes,
trains and automobiles,
you know,
then I'm going to get released.
But I know what to do.
I got to say to my wife and I swear to
God because every morning I do roll out
of bed.
Some nights you'd feel like you get hit
by a truck.
You know what I mean?
Sleeping is the worst thing for me
because I get in those positions that
I'm in and when I wake up I'm like,
Oh God,
but as soon as I do within eight
minutes,
I feel like a completely different
person.
So your disk though was completely gone?
No,
they're gone.
There was literally bone on bone.
And is it still like that?
Yeah,
but this is something I will try and
tell Joe,
which makes what I'm doing different
than regular yoga,
not just the.
I always say most Yogis are very,
not mistake ddpy way more t and a and I
met today the beginning,
but what I mean today is tone and
attitude because it's an attitude.
And so he switched it up.
He kept saying it worked,
it worked like that.
But,
uh,
you know,
it just,
it for me.
It's,
as you know,
this repetition is the mother of
learning where you do something the more
you own it.
And on that I want to,
I want to show you something that I
brought with me because I've been
waiting for your show to release this.
Oh,
I've got a new book coming out.
Ooh,
and no one seemed to cover yet and it is
taught here at Premiere Premiere and I'm
doing something I don't think anybody
I've ever has ever really done this.
Now this isn't the book itself,
this is just the cover since the plastic
plastic.
It's called positively unstoppable.
The Art of owning it.
Woo.
I like it.
What is it?
It's whatever the fuck you want to be.
Take that
diamond.
Dallas page pictures.
Beautiful.
Mick Foley wrote the the funniest,
most entertaining for what I want to get
that guy on the heights.
Hilarious.
Get that happen in a heartbeat.
He's friends with my friend Tony
Hinchcliffe,
who's a giant pro wrestling fan and it's
given me so much grief because Tony such
a fan,
I've made fun of wrestling because
Tony's a fan that
Tony is such a Dork for it.
They do this podcast at the comedy
store.
They,
what do they call it?
The four
know how and what is it not the four
horsemen?
No,
no,
no.
They have a wrestling podcast that I was
just done two weeks ago.
Store horsemen.
The store horseman,
the,
so these comics from the comedy store,
gigantic pro wrestling fans show.
Tell him I'll set it up,
I'll set it up.
And they do like simulcasts,
like so while Wrestlemania is going on,
they'll do like,
they'll do a view like,
uh,
we,
we do a thing for the UFC sometimes
called the fight companion.
Sure.
While the fights are going on,
we'll,
we'll get a bunch of guys in here,
drink beers and.
Beautiful.
I love that they do that while
Wrestlemania is going on.
Right?
So it's a.
on that note,
Jake,
the snake Roberts is going to,
he just,
he's working a deal right now with
hooters and in,
in Vegas and they're talking about
giving them a room and he will do,
like,
might be Monday night raw.
Somebody contacted me about him as well.
Someone from his organization contacted
me.
And you helped him.
Yes.
And I,
I saw uh,
some sort of a program on television was
detailing you helping him get cleaned
and you getting him involved in Yoga.
What you're doing is really fucking
awesome because you're.
You're exposing something that I think
should be.
It just just be something that everybody
does.
I just really think that all athletes,
all people.
I think yoga is a life staple.
I really didn't know.
I do do.
When I got through that I got through
with wrestling.
I could have easily stepped into that
yoga community and what the whole
namaste a route,
but that's not who I am and I know that
the yoga people like they get it.
They don't need me.
The people who need me is all those
people that bitterly,
that have nobody.
They don't have any direction.
You see the disabled veteran that I
helped.
No,
I did not.
I going to show you.
Just amazed that you could do what you
do with no disks.
Just don't understand that because
everybody that I know that it's had no
discussed had like serious muscle
atrophy and because they didn't stay,
didn't figure it out like I had to
figure it out.
What did you figure out the.
What did you do differently?
I love that shirt,
by the way.
Kills talent.
Yeah,
right.
What a fucking great church that you get
that.
That's my buddy josh.
You brought me in.
He's got a line called beverly kills.
That's a great shirt.
That's such a.
that's such a good point.
Does it really make the point?
I've been doing it because I knew you
would love it and I love the shirt.
I wear it all the time.
He's got a couple of them that are
really working so we can get that if
they wanted to buy the.
I think it's beverly [inaudible] dot
com.
I'm pretty sure.
So this is Arthur Boorman.
This is disabled veteran.
This is what DDP Yoga is,
or ddpy.
Oh Jesus.
Is there a link for this where Jamie
could get ahold of it?
He could put it on the youtube.
Absolutely.
If you're going to DDP yoga dot
com@thebottomofDDPyoga.com is the video
of Arthur.
So let me show you this now.
Jay,
show Jamie the image of him so he could
look for it on your website.
If you don't go all the way to the
bottom of DDP Yoga.com,
it will be sitting at the bottom and uh,
what was wrong with Arthur?
Okay,
let me,
let me just tell you the backstory.
It's crazy.
Anyone who got my program 11 years ago,
it was just workouts period and we're
three different levels and the first one
was called 50 plus.
It's Kinda like what I'm doing today
where I'm,
where I'm helping people who are really
disabled and he is right there.
You want to watch it?
Sure.
Okay.
Can we play this on Youtube?
Started from the beginning.
Start from the beginning.
This is awesome.
Dr told me I'd never walk unassisted
again.
It says,
so for the people just listening,
it says,
for 15 years doctors told me I would
never walk unassisted again.
And we're seeing this gentlemen with
those crutches,
cane things on his forearms.
I accepted this as fact.
I was a 47 year old disabled veteran and
I had basically given up.
I was injured as a paratrooper in the
Gulf War.
Too many jumps took its toll on his
back.
Oh Man.
Watch on his land and my knees.
It says gained weight.
We just watched an image of it.
All this stuff is available online at
DDP Yoga Dot com,
right?
Is that what it is?
This video?
Yes.
This has got Mozillians and millions of
views.
That's a good number.
It says he couldn't walk.
Run exercise seemed impossible.
Most Yoga instructors turned me away.
It's music is killing me
all,
but one mother fucker
says he didn't know me,
but he believed in me when no one else
did.
How long is this
video?
I feel like the payoff is worth it.
I will get them doing it here in the
chair.
Hold on
two for balance.
Will to get up,
get down.
Like says I fell many times.
Yeah,
but I got back up.
It's all about getting back up,
right?
Yeah.
This is very impressive,
but just watching him do what he's doing
here.
This guy's got heart.
You know?
It's the attitude to do something even
though it's difficult and in pain is so
damn important.
It is so important.
People have to force themselves to do
something and
this guy is one of the best examples of
that you're ever going to see.
I mean,
who?
Who had a better excuse to give up then
this guy.
Wow,
look at all this weight.
He's lost.
This is crazy.
He's a teacher in Baltimore.
He's lost a shitload of weight.
It looks like he's lost like eight
inches off of his belly
at least since I started to believe that
it could happen.
So in this,
uh,
this progress that you're seeing them
trying to walk without his cane and
fallen down flat on his face.
Yeah.
Starting to build his core strength.
This is crazy.
He's getting ready to do handstands now.
Oh my God.
If I crashed fucking China cabinet,
I love it.
It's going to kill the cat.
Get out of their cat.
He just said,
just because I can't do it today doesn't
mean it won't be able to do it someday.
A look at them here,
man.
Full pushups.
Wow.
Walk in with one cane now.
That's incredible.
What a difference in his posture and
everything.
Look how much weight he's lost.
And how often was he doing at every day?
Every day.
Sometimes twice a day.
So remember the pictures I showed you.
Right?
Check this.
I couldn't stand on two legs.
Now he's standing on one and holding his
foot up in the air.
That is insane.
Look out slimmy got holy Shit.
He lost 100 pounds in six months.
And he's holding that cat.
That cat is gonna die.
I told that cat get out.
Holy Shit.
He's running.
That is insane.
He's not just walking.
He's running Springton.
Holy Shit.
That is incredible.
That really is incredible.
Wow.
Look how fucking slamming he is.
That is really amazing.
What is the name of says?
Never give up.
What is the theme of this video so
people can find a.
never give up.
If you go to DDP Yoga Dot com and traded
the bottle.
Look at him.
Look at the difference.
And he looks like he's 10 years younger.
Lost 140 pounds in 10 months.
Holy Wait,
wait,
wait.
Whoa.
That is crazy.
Standing on his head.
That's so amazing,
man.
I'm going to show you a picture that no
one's seen this.
I'm saving this for a Ted talk that to
do and if everybody asked me a couple of
times to do it and I just wasn't ready,
but now I am.
I'm just waiting.
I'm waiting.
Eventually they're going to get a hold
of me again and I'm going to do it and
I'm going to base it around a crying
man.
A dud choke you up,
right?
I told you it was a payoff.
I mean like strong am I my business
partner.
Steve.
You put that together and I literally
did it with his son originally
and it was pretty good,
but steve just took it like he's the
same guy who directed the resurrection
of Jake the snake.
So let me finish with him in six months
and 10 months he lost the 140 pounds,
but fuck the weight because this is not
about weight loss.
It's just an awesome side effect.
And think about that with my shit.
You could lose weight,
but you know you can't out train a bad
diet.
So you got to do everything you've got
to,
more than anything,
change your mindset,
which is what positive.
The unstopables all about.
Changing your mindset have been owning
that inner voice.
The story you tell yourself.
So art for the last hundred and 40
pounds,
more importantly,
lots of knee braces,
back,
braces and canes.
Lost the neighbor.
No more knee braces.
Knee braces.
How did he do that?
Well,
let me finish.
Get knee braces and canes.
Not just to walk but run.
But this is what the program is really
about.
At one year he's five slash six so it
can put you over six foot two son.
That's insane.
Standing on his back while he's doing a
pushup in one year.
One year.
That's great.
Imagine if you didn't see him for a
year.
Hey males,
go have lunch.
I haven't seen you in a long time.
Like Woo Hoo,
fuck where's our.
And and that's really like.
It was crazy because again,
anybody,
you've got my program 11 years ago,
I personally,
there was no one else but me,
I would send me an email saying,
hey man,
I'm not trying to sell you anything.
You already bought the program and I
want to say thank you and I got a couple
of questions if you would answer my
depreciate it.
His answers were so good that I wrote
him back and I'd never written anybody
like directly that I did know at this
time and I wrote him back and I said,
it sounds like you need some help bro.
I said,
what's your story?
Cliff notes,
disabled veteran,
morbidly obese,
relegated to thinking of himself as a
piece of furniture.
So I say send me some pictures so I can
see what I was working with.
And those are the pictures,
those first two with the canes.
And I was like,
fuck man.
I don't know how I could help him
because it's not so much the knee
braces.
Hell,
I wore knee braces my whole career.
I didn't realize it was strapped to a
back brace in his wife 20 minutes every
morning.
Got To put it on the sleeve,
put on the brakes because he can't even
bend over enough to do it and so she
puts them all together.
Twenty minutes later he's going to the
bathroom with his canes,
so I sent them this food plan,
which is like my face,
three eating plan is for health,
but I got it from a guy named Dr Fred
vishy at a time.
Fred was 78,
could still run 20 miles on the beach in
the.
In the deep sand with my brother,
like as his mentor.
He helped people with cancer and all
sorts of shit.
This guy's like,
he's just a different level of lip
walking the talk.
So you have a food plan level was an
exercise plan and what kind of food you
got meet meeting.
Well this is what I like to do.
Let's go back to what God created.
Shit that's not genetically modified.
Alright Shit.
This not sprayed with chemicals,
so let's call it organic or like your
great grandparents used to call it
fucking food.
Like is everything go to Italy,
go to France.
They don't just say,
can I have the organic vegetables?
I go,
no.
What?
I like,
everything's fucking organic.
You're Bozo,
you know,
like that's the way it's supposed to be.
I mean,
when you look at just the,
the obesity,
heart disease,
cancer,
diabetes,
autism,
like how is it through the roof?
How are there 400 pound guys everywhere
25 years ago that didn't happen,
right?
You know,
and then they change everything as far
as I'm concerned.
There's three reasons why it could have
happened in because I don't know,
I'm not a scientist,
I'm fucking wrestler.
But I know when I get people to eat what
God created and stuff that's not
genetically modified,
I've found that they get out of pain and
that's what we did with Jake and Scott.
You know,
Razor Ramon also moved into my house and
then when you get a chance to watch
before you have Jay,
come on,
definitely watch a resurrection.
Jake the snake,
because I can set you up with that too.
Um,
but uh,
jake,
I got them eating real food and Scott
All Aka,
razor Ramon,
eating real food and within two weeks
they're already going to start getting
out of pain.
That's why I'm,
I eat the way I eat because I don't want
to feel like I'm 82.
I want to feel like I'm 42 at 62 now.
When you talk about your food plan,
like are you giving them specific
portions and what to eat?
Like how do you set it up on the APP?
Which right now are all.
Dude I've got,
I think I have the most extensive app on
the planet and it like just go to the
workouts and I'll come back to the
android and iphone everything.
And right now you can get it a lot about
windows phone.
I think it works on that thing.
Whatever it is,
we've set it up for everything that you
can use after the IPAD,
your computer.
And I didn't realize it at the time that
I set it up for the iphone,
the droid,
the IPAD,
the tablet and the computer.
Like going back in time,
I would've done the phone because in the
computer,
because you can have your phone go right
to the TV,
right if you've got an apple tv,
but I see it caused me a lot more money
to do it with all five units.
The bottom line is I created this thing
like from Arthur stuff,
I call it ddpy rebuilt.
You can't get out of bed.
You can't do the workout.
Bullshit.
I got three workouts in bed that have
nothing to do with fucking.
It's just friggin working out for 10
minutes.
Twelve minutes will get you up and I
called those bed flex.
Then I put you in chair force where
you're sitting in a chair.
I got eight workouts and I'd fucking
chair,
which gets you strong enough to hold the
so I call those stand strong like Arthur
was doing.
Help you get up,
help you get down,
help you balance healthy,
keep you from falling.
Then you're ready for beginner and once
you get the all the modifications that I
teach,
you will stand strong.
I got a guy who's 84 years old,
his name is Ted Evans.
He's been working with me since he was
68.
The motherfucker can do every workout.
I do.
Every workout now is modified times.
Yes,
but he can do every fucking workout I do
and it goes all the way to extreme
psycho shit.
Like I did a workout today where I took
my foot and held out in front of me and
held it for 30 seconds.
Then pulled it out,
This is all core stuff.
It's got to be to stuff.
God skips my mind right now,
the fighter of the UFC fighter.
I'm the French who was amazing.
Yes.
I mean,
nobody can ever take him down.
Yo.
They hook his leg and boom.
You're not taking him down.
He's going to hop around because his
core strength.
You had to be doing some of this type of
stuff.
A lot of gymnastics.
Well,
again,
those guys are super freaked.
Any as wrestlers or UFC guys,
I been there.
That's a whole different level.
And George Superior,
I will remember.
Why couldn't they?
Nobody's taking him down.
I don't care how they hook his leg,
so he really gets all of that inner
strength and that's really what I'm
doing at a level that you can start in
bed,
right?
So there's no more fucking excuse,
almost fucking excuses and that's so
important is because people can feel
sorry for themselves.
They can say they can't do it.
They don't have the energy there to beat
up.
That's bullshit.
There's always something you can do
that's always something if you.
But if you give yourself that fucking
excuse,
that's the problem.
What what I love about that video is if
anybody had an excuse,
it's that guy.
Absolutely.
That guy,
I mean two canes,
giant belly blown out,
knees blown out,
back veteran,
hire a trooper,
guide,
guide me jumping out of airplanes over
and over again.
Blows his body apart and you fixed it
and he fixed it.
He picks.
I just literally like so my credit.
So when I send them the food plant right
from,
from Fred Bushy,
his food plan because it just regular
food.
But like,
what do you have the meeting like
chicken,
let's,
let's say there's so alleged people's,
you'll hear me say in my program over
and over and over and over and over
again.
Make the DDP why your own bike.
And I explained to Arthur when I called
him.
Well here's what happened.
So he,
um,
[inaudible],
I sent him the food plan.
Let me say it again.
If he writes me back,
I think I can do it.
I'll give it a try.
You go crazy.
No,
I go,
hey,
awesome.
Keep me posted.
But he said four words or he wrote for
words.
I can do this.
I said,
give me your number right now.
And I call it the motherfucker up.
If you say you can use,
say you can't,
you're right.
You know that you say you can or you
can't.
You're right.
She said that originally who Henry Ford
is,
right?
Yeah.
And I always say,
what the fuck did he ever do know what
the fuck did he ever do?
But for when he said I can do it,
I said,
give me your number.
So I called them and I said,
yeah,
we talked for about an hour.
Two weeks later he calls me back.
The main thing talked to him in,
in,
in that conversation,
which is again what positively
unstoppable is all about.
As important as the workout is,
as important as the eating plan is the
10 percent of the equation,
the 90 percent is right between your
ears right here,
that six inch piece of real estate,
the story you tell yourself,
and I said,
if you can really just get past that
story and start
telling yourself a different story.
An example would be when I had,
when I went up from my hall of Fame
Induction Speech in front of 20,000
people in millions of people on USA and
on the wwe network,
which is only nine 99,
by the way,
it's like a rib bottom line is,
is that I wasn't in the back going,
Oh God,
I hope I don't fuck this up.
Oh God.
What if I forget was going to say,
Oh God,
this sucks,
but what if I.
What if I fuck up?
I wouldn't say.
Now I'm saying this can be the best
thing I've ever done.
I'm going to blow people away and make
them laugh.
Make them cry.
I'm going to inspire them,
and that was my inner voice.
I went out there to the best thing I've
ever done,
like it's the best thing I've ever done,
but it's about that story that you tell
yourself when you get all this shit and
that's why people listen to you because
they need to be reminded it over and
over and over again.
You know,
the way you think about things is so
important.
It's so important.
It's almost more important than the
facts,
right?
The Way and the way this guy decided
that he was going to change his life,
that that video is so important to
people.
I mean,
if there's ever.
That's the best testimonial video you're
ever going to say ever.
I mean,
that guy is as broken as they get.
I mean he's basically,
I easily could have been in a wheelchair
easily or like was it announced a time
he was going around,
you know,
like any kind of,
go to the unit of the airport,
where do they put you in which in a
wheelchair because it's too hard for too
hard for him to walk around.
And again,
going back to eating.
So back to the law,
what do you get them,
you know?
Well again,
I use,
I get a make the GDP wider owner.
You can do Paleo if you want to do
Paleo,
you can do this Keto Diet,
whatever you're doing with that.
I tried to say if you're early on in
your young,
you know,
I encourage them to do calorie counting,
calories in,
calories out,
but a lot of people that doesn't work
for anymore.
So what I get them to do is go gluten
and dairy free.
And really I started with gluten free.
If you can go and people go gluten free,
I said,
all's I know is the people I work with
get out of pain.
I'm one of them.
So I don't give a fuck if you eat gluten
or not.
I don't care about the gluten fucking
Nazis.
I'm fucking like,
hey dude,
what the fuck you want to do?
But this is what I do.
This is what him and her and him and her
do and look at them and it just helps
drop weight.
It's about inflammation in your body.
Go back to icing your body sugar,
which were all at explored.
I try to get him to cut down as much as
they can.
Some people quit completely,
which blows my mind,
which tells me they really have that
substance by my friend Stacy Morris who
lost a 180 pounds in 18 months.
She's actually on the cover of women's
Day right now,
that big magazine for women's Day of her
transformation.
She wrote a book on it,
like something comfort,
fuel it,
eating comfort or family comfort.
You can catch it up on my site.
It's up there,
but she wrote this book about eating
without sugar and that's like,
I'm not telling anybody do that because
I can't do that up.
Your right.
I want us to delete the sugar I just
don't use,
but you're not,
you're just not being a glutton.
And I'm eating good sugars like the
honey that I'm putting in this gimmick
is organic honey.
So,
um,
the,
the food part for pretty inflammation
would be the sugar,
dairy and wheat and gluten.
Get those out of your body.
I challenge you.
You.
Have you ever gone to gluten free?
No,
I have.
And how much better did you feel?
Feel really good.
Look,
I,
I'm basically gluten free all the time
except for I take cheat days.
Oh sure.
I'll take a cheat day and I'll have a
bowl pasta.
But for the most part I rarely eat bread
and I rarely read anything.
Pasta or anything with wheat will let me
give you this two and a half weeks.
Let me give you an alternative.
I love Pasta
and the Irish,
German,
Dutch kid,
but all my best friends were Genta
Pharaoh.
So
Rossi,
I read all my buddies will go mas,
you know.
And so I love Italian food.
I fucking love it.
So there's a,
there's a company called Tink,
Yada.
That's the best pasta I've ever had in
some brown rice pasta,
so there's always a substitute when you
get that out of your body in two and a
half,
three weeks,
it's a different level job like you've
already feel better,
you feel better,
but it's got to get out of your body and
then if you put it back in,
you know,
here and there you're going to run late,
but it's going to go away quick because
it doesn't have all that shit stored in
your body.
You know,
it also reminds me how shitty I feel
after I eat it when I do eat a pizza
laid on the couch,
like a,
like a lead weights in my stomach.
But what I substituted with his
spaghetti squash,
I lost.
That is an awesome choice.
Getty squash with some garlic and
Marinara sauce.
It's fantastic and that's one of the
guilt free.
That's one of our recipes,
like the way our,
our APP is set up or DDP Yoga now app
and like I said,
anybody wants to try it?
Fuck it costs you nothing.
Go try it for seven days.
You like it,
like it not get out of it?
I don't give a fuck.
I mean I don't.
I mean I only want people want to put
the work in.
Some people will say to me,
well,
how much do I have to do it?
I say,
you don't,
you don't have to fucking do it.
I don't want you to do it.
I want you to own it and really do it or
not and I'll try to inspire you because
every,
every Monday I've got motivational
Mondays on the APP.
Every Monday I'm doing another story
about something I saw and I'm bringing
it to you.
It could be three minutes,
it could be eight minutes,
but it's going to zip video on the APP.
Is that it's,
it's one.
There's 150 of them up there because
I've been doing it for two and a half
years and then there's every week we
have a new recipe come out and I'm not
just gonna tell you what's in it and how
to make it.
I'm going to fucking show you how to
make it because we got in our DDP Yoga
performance center,
which is in Smyrna,
Georgia,
which by the way,
every first time you come in there,
it's free.
Name me another fucking gym or something
like that that does that.
How far is that from Dallas or Atlanta?
Atlanta rather.
Well,
it's literally 20 minutes.
Twenty minutes from the heart of
Atlanta.
I mean Atlanta when I'm doing a Gig,
I'm going to stop it.
Dude.
State you're going to stay.
I have.
I just bought a crib that literally one
of my buddies,
titus who's from the wwe is coming in on
Tuesday to train with me.
I got a hyperbaric chamber now.
Whoa.
Yes.
12 Psi.
I got a cryo system in my house.
I would about float tanks.
I don't have that.
You ever fuck with one?
You know I haven't because I'm Kinda
gonna be some right here,
buddy.
I'm really.
I'm kind of scared of that because it's
been about is
how will you scared you?
Other people you're screaming against?
No,
I do,
but I'm being honest bro.
When I first got into one,
can I get you in one today?
You know what?
Yes,
that's right.
You got to get.
You don't want to have one in your
house.
I guarantee you.
Most relaxing thing ever.
Okay.
What would you get?
I can easily get out of there.
I just pushed the door open.
Okay,
cool.
So you know,
only because it's you because you
inspired.
You inspire the fuck out of me.
Like I was.
This was so crazy.
I mutual.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
You know,
I uh,
I knew we were going to get long lake
incredibly.
But,
but here's what happened.
I,
I've been reaching out to different
people like Eddie Bravo.
He's like,
he's a buddy of mine and I just got a
disc replaced.
He really had a lower back.
His disc was so bad he could barely get
out of bed and he had a titanium
articulating disk put in his back.
He feels way better now.
Yeah.
And he gained an inch five nine now,
which,
which is pretty sweet because of all the
technology that they had.
It's really incredible.
That can help this,
this were all smashed from Jujitsu,
especially lower back though.
I've always said like Eddie Bravo,
like he did what they did.
Your Jitsu community would have done in
the uh,
in the yoga community.
Just take a totally different path,
right?
Like,
I don't want to be in the yoga world.
I'm going to be way the fuck over there.
I want to be the different guy then.
But we were just talking about where we
were talking right before that.
So no,
nothing that I,
I,
I reached out to a bunch of different
guys.
I like,
I've heard you talk about,
you know,
dvp why and what we're doing and you've
talked about a lot of cool stuff,
you know,
and you've segwayed me into a couple of
like I got to get on his show and I
think we'll get amazing.
We'll get along amazingly.
And then I saw on youtube it was a um,
somebody put together like a bunch of
your clips from the show and I'm
listening to it.
I'm like,
man,
this motherfucker sounded just like me.
I mean,
I got to get on his show and I
literally,
when I finished watching it,
I literally looked up,
I went,
God,
I'm thrown us out in the universe.
I want to get on Rogan show within the
next year,
two days later,
you dme,
two days later you dm me today,
Brian into Dmu forever.
It's one of those things where it's just
unfortunately or fortunately,
there's just so many different requests
for people to come on the podcast.
I can't keep up.
No,
I get it.
It's just I can't.
It's impossible for.
Have you been in the back of my head for
a long time and I think that yoga,
like I said,
it's so important and I think what
you've done is make it accessible to
people that wouldn't have considered it
before.
All right.
You got to do me and favor.
Okay.
What I got to do when you're talking
about what the fuck I do.
Ddpy.
Ddpy Yoga?
Yes.
Because it's different,
you know,
mainly because people put it in a box
and you get it.
Will you?
Will you do a workout with me?
Yes.
I would love to.
A robbery did it,
my partner and on it.
Yes.
He loved it.
He said,
dude,
it's bad ass.
He said he's definitely doing something
different.
His his take was,
he's like,
he's got,
he's doing yoga.
He goes,
but he's got a whole nother edge to it
and I keep again,
making it my own and I encourage
everybody.
What's really cool about.
I've got some workouts that have me in
like two people or four people behind me
and they're like the introductory.
There's always someone modifying.
Like when I first started doing yoga,
no one modified shit.
They never told you.
So I had to figure this shit out.
So anything I did,
I gave you a more.
How do you make this easier step in
lower do we need,
don't blow yourself out.
Now the thing that you don't know,
and I gave you one of Mark DDP Yoga mats
with the bag inside,
it is a bluetooth heart monitor and what
that's going to do is connect right to
the APP.
So are you an iphone guy or droid?
I have iphone,
but I'm gonna switch over either
bullshit.
Oh,
I get that too,
but I'm sort of like a,
um,
an attic of not wanting to learn again,
but you know,
they got that mirror and things so it
pops right up on your TV,
up there will come where your heart
rate's at.
Oh Wow.
And then it tracks you at the end of it.
How long have you not been in your zone?
How long have you been in your zone and
how long have you been over years old?
Think about this.
Who did this APP for you?
Myself,
Steve,
you,
who's the president of our company.
And we hired these guys out of Turkey
because they were all went,
they all went to Georgia tech and it's
way cheaper,
but it's,
you know,
it's been a long.
I got probably coming up on $3,000,000
in it.
Jesus crowd to it's lasted.
It's extensive,
you know,
and again,
there's a lot of interaction with it,
you know.
So,
um,
the actual,
uh,
we make it like a video game at the end.
So when it gets to the end,
you'll
get to the end of brothers exactly what
I wanted to hit the next level.
So when you're putting all this stuff
together,
like this has got to be a long process
of refining and getting it just right.
I mean this must have taken over your
life.
Oh,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
But I go on the road all the time.
I do comic con.
Do you ever do comicon?
No.
I've never done.
I want to do you have to.
You will fucking have a line for ever.
I used to be a comic book Dork,
man.
I had to sell them on when I was poor.
I used to.
I had all these comic books that I
collected from the time I was a little
kid and then when I became a standup
comedian and I was starving in the early
days,
I sold all my comic books and just,
it's just a bummer man.
I'm scared to go look at comic books
again.
Don't,
don't,
don't do that because it'll disappear.
Do you know Adi Shankar is?
No.
Did you see,
um,
there was a power ranger bootleg video
that came out like maybe four years ago,
five years ago,
it was five years ago and it blew up on
Youtube.
Got like 5 million views,
which you know,
back then that was fucking huge because.
So I'm the guy who owns,
owns a power,
just put a lawsuit on it and youtube and
they had to pull it off.
Next thing you know,
he's on CNN and they're asking her about
it and he's like,
fuck him.
He goes,
he doesn't mean we're not trying to make
money.
We're not monetizing this.
And next,
you know,
he pulled the thing off your suit off
and now it's like $22 million and this
is something that he did because he
produced a bunch of movies,
but they kept changing and shit,
like wouldn't let him do what he wants
to do.
And like freshman was judge dredd in
five years ago or a little before that.
He's telling me how he's going to do
this shit on Youtube,
but I'm like,
what the fuck do you mean you're going
to put shorts on youtube when he did
that one?
It's got 22 million views right now.
And that really became like this
underground,
you know,
Yoda type person of the Internet.
And uh,
he sent me a script about three years
ago when we started.
It's called Gods and it's kind of like,
you know,
every,
all superheroes,
as you know,
they're all slightly different but the
same.
And uh,
it's a very dark,
dark superhero series that will,
when you get to the fighting part of,
or remind you of like,
Fart,
you know,
from the Nih,
from the eighties frigging video to
combat shit like that meets a really
dark story that uh,
it's going to be a netflix original.
So.
Oh,
that's something.
Something to why,
what only call I think you'll,
I think you'll dig it.
I love the watchman.
It's kind of a little bit like that,
but not.
I was open to it.
We're going to do a sequel.
And I had heard that they weren't they
planning on that,
Jamie,
is that,
that's something they're working on.
It was so good.
I was like,
how are they,
how did they not follow up on this?
I don't know.
You know,
but we're going to.
We have,
like I say,
it's in the process right now,
putting together.
He's the brains behind it,
but it's something.
I'm speeding.
You
were into comics systems stuff be on hbo
go.
Oh Shit,
right.
I heard that.
Uh Oh.
But different people,
Huh?
Oh,
interesting.
All right,
well I'm down for that.
Yeah,
I'll check it out.
Mitch.
Be Oh man.
They got to pick up the slack.
Netflix coming in strong are like,
fuck man.
Gather up the troops.
Was a war going on?
Fucking ozarks back,
baby.
Woo Woo.
On two episodes in a good show.
Did you.
Did you see the first center center?
Oh No,
I haven't seen that show heard.
That's very good.
That's just the deal,
dude.
They made her look confusing people.
You're around her.
You like,
I don't know what my opinions are.
I'm going to change them.
You tell me what your opinions are.
I'll take those.
She,
she looked,
she comes off as really like girl mc
storage,
but that,
that frigging show right there.
My wife and Brenda and my,
my daughter Lexie,
she was there.
We watched all eight episodes.
Sam by one after another on a Sunday
afternoon.
We were like pulled in sheet.
My wife had seen a printed scene.
They were playing it on the plane and
she,
when she came back she was like,
we have.
I couldn't finish watching it.
You've got to get this.
I'll watch it from the beginning.
Getting snack.
Good.
It's fam shows now.
It's a really interesting time to be a
consumer.
Oh,
absolutely,
man.
Yeah.
I'm big on the Netflix and a sneaky
pete.
Did you ever see any of that?
Got Hurt.
That's great.
That's an Amazon,
right?
Amazon.
Yeah.
Everyone's just that Goliath is supposed
to be fantastic on Amazon too.
That's that Billy Bob Thornton,
who I loved the first season.
I,
I haven't got through the second one
yet,
but uh,
it's a crazy time.
Have you thought about doing something
like that?
Like maybe on a Netflix or something
along those lines,
like having like a sort of like
inspirational clips mixed in with your
workouts,
with these people showing
transformations.
Um,
you know,
a good friend of mine,
great idea.
Do you know tim?
Tim?
Say as I know the name.
Yeah,
he was Howard Stern's.
that's fine.
That's name.
And he just came up to me.
He was at that show I was telling you
about all when this weekend and he was
like,
dude,
twitches the future.
You got to do something with this.
And I know I've heard it twitch,
but it was like video game,
you know,
people watch a video game stuff.
He said,
yeah,
but it's going to go to a whole new
level and sapiens a really smart guy and
I'm actually helping him get back on
track with his health.
So he's going to come to Atlanta and see
me.
He's going to talk to me and Steve and
figure out what we do.
I can,
I,
I'm all over.
This company would never be successful
without the Internet,
without people sharing that Arthur video
everywhere,
you know?
And there's so many other videos that
we've had go viral.
One of my favorites,
and I'll,
I'll get this to you.
My buddy named Mark Morrow,
he's a former wrestler,
marvelous Marc Mero back when we rustled
gabby was johnny be bad.
And he changed his name from John into
mark [inaudible].
His real name was mark two hydro
projects.
Real bad was bad.
He actually was actually actually Mark
Morrow is a four time New York Empire
State Games boxing champion.
Yeah.
From back in the day when he was a kid.
But uh,
he,
he's become this inspirational speaker.
Two kids.
I've never seen anybody move kids the
way he does.
So he was in Atlanta one day and I set
my crew on it because I got a whole
production studio like resurrection.
We filmed that,
we edit it,
we did everything.
And um,
I sent my crew down there to just go
down and film them.
And Steve took this one part where he
talks about his mom now.
No bullshit.
Go.
I can show you how this one four minute
clip that Steve produced has over a half
a billion views on facebook.
Like half a billion and now mark went
from having trouble getting booked at
high schools to being in such demand
that he had his.
He had 3000 requests the month that that
video went crazy and people keep taking
it and putting it out there,
but he,
he connects with kids.
It starts out with,
I want to be rich,
I want to be famous.
And then he showed you,
as you know,
what can come with that if you're not
mentally prepared to handle that.
And I don't know how any fucking kid can
be 18,
19,
20 years old.
I don't think they can.
Yeah.
We'll never seen anybody succeed.
Lebron,
you know?
Yeah.
He.
But you know what?
I think one of the reasons why a guy
like him has succeeded because his
success comes along with athletic
performance,
right?
Like it's not just like being Justin
bieber being some sort of a musical
superstar.
I think the struggle of the athletic
pursuit is one of the things that keeps
you humble because there's no way to get
around the work and the work keeps you
humble.
There's no,
I mean to kind of work that you have to
put in to be Lebron James.
I don't care how genetically gifted he
is.
Clearly he's a fucking freak athlete.
Ridiculous.
But he's also.
But he's also got a powerful mind when
you hear that guy talk.
There was some sort of a round table
thing he was doing.
I don't know if you saw this with John
Stewart and a few other people.
Is that his show?
When that guy talks?
What is it called?
What is it?
The barbershop.
Oh Gosh,
I love the prom.
When he talks,
you go,
okay,
there's a fucking nuclear furnace burden
inside that guy.
That's why he's so successful.
It's not just him being a freak athlete.
It's the mind his mind,
but that hard work and that dedication
and his mind is the reason why he's
still so good and keeps it together at,
you know,
what is he 35 now?
Thirty three,
33.
It's been around forever.
Been around for a long time,
but been super fucking successful for a
long time.
Ridiculous.
Never fucked up.
Never drove his car into a tree.
Never punched a cop,
never got crazy.
I mean he's,
he's kept it together in a rare way that
very few superstars do because it's a,
you know,
it,
I mean,
you,
I'm sure you went from when you first
started into pro wrestling to becoming
super famous.
It's an an intoxicating
drug.
Absolutely.
And it's a confusing drug.
It confuses the shit out of a lot of
people.
Fortunately for you,
you are already a man.
Right?
And that was the big difference.
I was just say starting at 35 was the
worst thing physically because bill one
of my matches or any of these kids that
it's like four or five car accidents.
One match.
Yeah.
Every,
every night.
And I said is,
you know,
as hard as it was starting at 35,
the really positive side was as 35.
So I was much smarter and discipline,
more mature way more.
And you know,
that I was telling you about when you
come to Atlanta,
you're going to stay at my place because
my,
my wife is amazing.
We have the best bed and breakfast and
there's like five rooms that are all
king size beds because again,
I'm getting ready to work with top
athletes.
You look at Lebron,
you look at Brady,
how do they perform such a,
especially brady at being 40 years old
now.
Pretty amazing.
It's,
but it's the way he eats,
which is pretty much the way I eat.
Isn't he a Vegan though?
Um,
he's really.
He doesn't lagoon.
It's very strict.
Again,
way I eat.
I still want the beef I still want,
but I don't eat it all the time now
where I used to eat that shit all the
time.
I used to eat 12 eggs in the morning,
now I eat eight,
know five yolks,
three whites,
but against keeping the protein.
But,
but he's eating for health,
let's just call it that.
And he's not beating up his body outside
of what he's doing.
When he gets hit,
he beats up his body.
But before that all he's doing is
strengthening his body.
And that's what DDP wise,
it's strengthening you.
Like I just was reading something.
I love that,
that girly didn't.
Todd didn't play in any preseason stuff
this year.
You don't need that.
You're going to be out there.
He's going to be in the best shape,
but it's not going to have put his body
already through abuse,
you know,
so it's just like wherever you can,
everything that you do with your Jitsu,
mma,
UFC,
nfl,
getting to the show is the thing.
And when you get to the show,
you have two jobs.
One be the best player.
You can be the best performer too.
Don't get hurt.
You know what's crazy about Tom Brady?
He looks like someone's Dad.
Like you see them on the bed.
You don't look like,
you know,
you see Herschel Walker without a shirt
off you go,
Jesus fucking Christ.
What lab was that guy?
You see Tom Brady like,
oh,
there's Mike's dad.
He's totally normal.
Look it.
I mean,
he doesn't look bad.
He looks like he's in good shape.
There he is.
Look at that,
but what the fuck?
What the fuck?
How's that possible?
The greatest quarterback of all time.
That's Mike's dad.
Work Ethic,
but it's his obviously his mind too.
I mean,
that's fucking insane and that guy ain't
sucking in his gut for anybody.
You could suck his dick.
How about that?
That's not sucking in his back.
He lets that thing hanging out.
I mean it's,
it's a couple of inches over his fucking
shorts.
Who let him let him relax.
Get that gorgeous wife with him.
He's covering her.
Jessica Biel together.
Created some sort of a nuclear
explosion.
Too Hot.
Yeah.
It's crazy,
but it's crazy.
It's about healing your body and
especially when you're in that spot and
that's what I can do for these guys and
you'll see as we,
as we work out,
you'll get it and you know,
is everything.
I want to go back to your back.
See,
this is what I don't understand.
When the conventional wisdom is,
when it's bone on bone,
like you're fucked,
there's too much inflammation,
there is too much grinding and you're
just going to be too painful to do
anything and you're gonna have to do
some sort of a surgery.
How?
How does the Yogis does it?
Because the muscle strength in the DDP.
Why are we can.
Sorry.
How does the DDP wise do that?
Does it?
Just the strengthening all the core
muscles around your spine stabilizes
everything and keep moving.
The only thing I can remember,
Joe,
I'm a wrestler.
I'm not a nightclub nightclub owner,
friggin.
I've been working in the bar business my
whole life.
That's what I did before this.
Um,
but I,
for some reason I'm just gifted with
figuring shit out.
Like on my app,
there's a guy named Jerry Cameron
disable that in wheelchair for two and a
half years.
There's no way to lose six to 40 looks
great,
but he's got the walker that he got
after two and a half years of being in
the chair,
got himself out the old.
This is all my app or my in my law,
we can rebuild you.
I'm doing my own little shell.
We can rebuild you.
I'd trademark that name and you remember
what that's from $6,000,000.
We can rebuild you.
So that's our thing.
So Jerry,
we have him in.
We over the seven week period now.
He's got a long way to go still,
but you will be so amazed.
Every show that comes up,
how he gains just a little bit more
little incremental stuff.
Exactly.
Input the confidence and like we,
we reached out to our community in
Smyrna,
Georgia and we said we're looking for
people that want our help,
cost him nothing.
If you'll be part of our group and we
can track you,
you can come,
go do our stuff,
you know.
And we gave,
we gave them the APP,
we set them up and out of the 12 or 13
and started,
we still have like seven and this is
like eight weeks later.
And to see their stories,
like we follow them,
every couple of weeks will pop up and
show where they're at and what they're
doing.
But Jerry,
I got special spot.
Might just like you do for military
guys.
You know,
I've been to Iraq three times.
Afghanistan once you've done those
tours.
Thirteen days.
I haven't done it yet.
No.
Oh you should go.
They would freak the fuck out over you.
Um,
they would love you.
But I started in 2004 with that shit.
And over that period,
the shrine Williams.
What was getting shot down a?
No,
no,
no.
I just,
I hate.
No,
I did not add anything.
What?
I'm sorry to interrupt you.
The bottom line is I have a fond spot
for those guys and I have some things I
do as well.
Yeah,
I know.
And there's something I'm about to do
off of my app that's going to be life
changing for a lot of those guys.
I just don't have it all put together
yet,
but it's a,
it's one of the things that I'm working
on right now because I want to be able
to give back to help them.
I do stuff with their organizations.
They're real people start.
I'm like,
I just did one with Mod deuce deuce in
um,
in um,
New Jersey where I'm from.
Like I've lived in point pleasant
bricktown to the next town over and I
went over there and I did one for the
guys there and it was,
had like 75 guys there and guys and
their families and uh,
every one of those disabled bedsides
gave them the APP,
you know,
because I just want you to do it because
if you do it,
you're going to feel better.
I don't know how much better,
how much work are you going to put in
and you know,
it all comes down to the work ethic.
Like where you are,
how much work you put in,
where can you get right in.
We're it,
I,
my program meets you where you are.
And that's the whole thing with Jerry to
watch where he is on the last episode.
I won't tell you what happened because I
know eventually you'll get around to it
and you're going to be like,
wow,
this fucking shit's crazy and for,
to answer your question on the back,
all I can think of is I'm constantly
lengthening and strengthening.
Like I stretched my whole wrestling,
my whole athletic career right up those
42 and three quarters when I blew my
back out.
I stretch.
So stretching is great,
but it's not the end all be all.
I'm stretching and strengthening the
muscles,
ligaments and tendons.
When you use the resistance and a
dynamic time under tension,
when you do that,
it elevates your heart rate.
Think about this.
You're at the head laying down your
heart rate's the lowest ever,
right?
Sit Up.
What happened?
Your heart rate goes up,
stand,
walk,
jog,
sprint,
boom,
boom.
That's what I'm doing.
When I had you flex your quads,
flexed your glutes,
grab the ball,
openness,
fingers,
wide movement,
resistance of guarantee.
Your heart rate.
If you're starting at 80,
it went to 105.
One hundred and 15 or 20.
I can take my heart rate from 90 to 140
by 135 like that,
and I mean two minutes standing still
and that's not yoga.
That's DDP.
Why?
And I've been wearing a heart monitor
doing this for over 18 years,
so it's more physically intensive.
It can be more strength.
It can be,
like I said,
I did 10,
ten second pushups almost second
birthday.
So you,
but you still haven't gotten an MRI done
some.
I've done.
So you just figured fuck.
It feels good.
Going to pay for that to see what it is
because I know that there are,
it is possible to gain some space.
Oh,
I believe it has to be there.
They've done it with decompression.
They've done it with,
uh,
you know,
various exercises and things that people
do that do lengthen the spine,
stretch you out.
And there's A.
I have a bunch of things out back.
I'll show you some of the things that
they,
they've people have created to
decompress the spine,
you know.
Do you ever use one of those teeter
things where you hanging clinicals a
lot.
I literally get out of my hyperbaric
chamber.
Let's talk about that.
What do you know about?
Never done it,
but I've heard amazing things from UFC
guys that have fought and had pretty
significant injuries,
handbrakes muscle damage and gotten
there and had some pretty,
pretty rapid recovery because of it.
My,
my,
my doctor who she's my endocrinologist
when I told her I was doing and she
goes,
Old Dallas,
I can tell you I,
I know it can only help you.
She goes,
the only story I have about,
I don't know enough about it.
She said I had a woman who had radiation
therapy,
so she had an open wound from her breast
cancer and it wouldn't close for over
two years,
centered down to emory.
Finally put her night Berg Chamber.
Three months later,
100 percent healed.
Same things happens with people with
diabetes.
So I had heard like Lebron had it,
you know,
because I don't,
I never saw an article on him,
but I just heard people talking about
it,
you know,
in different areas that he had won.
Coby had one.
They have them in their house.
That's what I heard.
I don't know if they do or they don't.
I just heard it.
So it got me thinking in my house that I
was just,
I just let it.
It's called the accountability crib and
I'm about to put this out there
everywhere.
It's when I moved jake into my home in
Atlanta,
I just bought it and it was all about
being accountability.
One of my friends,
Christina and uh,
sent me a list of names.
I want to call this something.
I put it out there on the Internet and
she sent me like 22 names and one of
them is the accountability crib.
So that's what I call it DDPS
accountability crib.
And you got to be accountable for
everything.
And the thing,
I love that home,
but it was 22 steps to get to my bedroom
and my knees are bone on bone.
So going down was a drag.
So I figured fuck it,
I'm going to buy a new home master on
main and I'm going to build this,
you know,
I have this place that I can bring in
top athletes that want to be healed,
you know.
So going back to the crib,
I'm making that like an airbnb now.
And,
or have like the steak Robert Suite,
the um,
uh,
the uh,
razor Ramon suite to DDP sweet.
Yeah.
So that'll be pretty cool.
That's going to happen next week.
We're going to get into is hyperbaric
chamber.
Great.
Why doesn't Lebron Shave his head?
What's going on with that?
Someone explained that there's some so
much fuckery going on with his hair.
Wow,
okay.
That looks a lot,
but mine.
I would venture to say that he is not at
12 psi on that thing and what that means
is pounds per square inch.
If you're like 10,
say 10 feet below sea level,
that's about four pounds per square
inch.
You get know it just goes up.
Twenty would be like eight,
eight pound per square at 12 pounds per
square inch.
The pressure is there.
An takes like 10 minutes to get up
there.
Like you're blowing your nose.
Like wow.
You know,
like just getting air,
getting your,
you'll fix your ears and all that shit.
But what happens when you get to 12 psi
now it breaks the brain barrier and the
oxygen will go to your brain.
So this is.
I didn't know any of this shit till I
sit next to a guy named Brad Campbell
who's like an angel,
this cat.
And we just started talking on a plane
and at some point I said,
man,
how old are you anyway?
Sounds like you do a lot of shit.
And he says,
I'm thinking.
He looks at the Max 45,
maybe 40.
He goes,
I'm 57.
I go,
you're 57.
I said,
how the fuck you look like that?
He said,
I've been living in a hyperbaric chamber
for the last 14 years.
So he's a Weirdo kid away from me.
Right.
I said,
how did that happen?
Is that I was diagnosed with ms 22 years
ago.
Oh Wow.
Right.
And using that to keep the MS and check.
He told me that when he gets a 12 PSI
and it goes to your brain,
and this would be layman's terms.
Okay.
Like when you get ms kind of like
crystallized on your brain,
right?
And when the crystals fill up,
where do they go next down your spine,
hence became the Walker,
the chair.
So what somebody.
I don't know who the person was who
figured out 20 days in a chamber.
And it's all about consistency.
You do it once or twice,
you're going to feel better a little
bit,
but you do it like consistent,
like 20 days,
like they do their take off five days.
You do that four times.
You do your Mri on your brain before you
start and after there's a kid named
Daniel Bryan who is one of the biggest
stores in professional wrestling and a
couple of years ago he had to retire at
the height of his career and he was the
hottest guy on the planet at the time
and he wasn't a big guy,
but he was the number one guy in the
business and he had to retire because of
concussions.
Well,
he's back and I haven't talked to them
directly about this,
but I did hear that he was using a
hyperbaric chamber to help heal his
brain.
Now again,
while he's telling me this story,
I'm not thinking about them as,
but I'm thinking I've been hit in the
head a lot.
You know,
I've been knocked out a shitload of
time,
but I knocked out a shit load of guys by
accident.
But you know,
they weren't trying to knock me out
either,
but it's not checkers out there.
So it I've been hit in the head with
chairs and all that shit.
So how do you guys do that?
How do you hit some of these?
Supposed to go with it.
Here's the deal.
If I walk up to you and we're about to
go out there and I'm going to slap the
shit,
I don't do it anymore.
But in the old days if I'm going to hit
you in a chair,
you got to hit it like even right?
I'd say,
hey dude,
I'm going to say I'm sorry right now.
And you would say back to me and we'll
come with a motherfucker.
Don't make it weak.
I mean that's what you would say because
if we're going to shoot an angle on it,
let's go with it.
But don't you think that back when you
were 35,
they didn't understand traumatic brain
injury.
That's why they let us do it.
They don't want to.
They don't see that anymore.
But you remember when Dennis Rodman
wrestled?
Yes.
Well,
that was when I got Karl Malone involved
and it was me and Karl Malone against
Rodman and Hogan.
It was fucking huge.
I took my name to a different level,
but robin was supposed to be a practice
that day in Detroit.
We were in Detroit that night with metro
and he,
him and Hogan.
I'm about to do this announcement and
him and Hogan come from the back and
whack me with chairs.
Now this is Dennis Rodman.
Alright.
Right.
He's not one of the boys.
He doesn't know.
You've got to lay it flat if you in and
there's a,
there was some big like probably like a
mat,
you know,
from a wrestling like the collegiate
wrestlers wrestle on.
So this big roll of rubber was there.
It was probably about three feet off the
ground.
And I said,
I know you've never swung a chair
before,
so let me show you something.
And I picked my hands up with a chair
and then I'd lower him down just right
on top of it.
Then I'd pick them up at low room flat.
I said,
you see,
I'll flag it is right.
And I took it up and I hit it as hard as
I could.
Boom.
I said,
if you hit me like that,
we're good.
And then I just turned with my left
hand,
move down a little more.
So now the railing of the chair headed
and to put a big getting it.
I said,
if you hit me like that,
you break my rips.
I said,
so please let me see you do it.
Hit a fly.
He was great,
you know?
And they came out and it was on espn
that night because he was supposed to be
a practice and hear his fucking around
with us.
So on a shoot and the angle or metro.
So it was pretty cool.
But it's all about laying it flat and
then you'll see how it's not checkers,
it's not fucking checkers.
The one of the most disturbing things I
ever saw was brock lesnar doing that
flip off the top rope and landing on his
head.
Oh my God.
Not a lot of human beings that would
even survive that.
And then he goes on to complete the pin.
He,
how the fuck did he not get knocked
unconscious from that and how the fuck
did he not have permanent spinal injury
from that and he is 300 pounds at the
time.
I tell everybody,
you know what you fucking want about
fresh and wrestling.
You can't fake gravity.
That little fucker that was flipping in
the air.
I mean he's,
he's the baddest motherfucker alive as
far as our maturity survived the hundred
pounds flying through the air,
landing on the top of his neck.
And then you watched it was this,
here was this shared heritage with look
at the size of the is.
Oh,
that is so fucked up.
That is so fucked up.
Look at him grabbing his head.
Oh,
I mean he landed on his fucking head.
How is he alive?
I don't know.
He's not.
I missed that.
So bad is Cyborg.
Know.
I mean he's one of the best fuckers
landed
on his head and this was before and look
at this and the other band is
motherfuckers right there.
Next door was also completely fucked up
from wrestling.
I mean,
his arms,
both of his arms were completely
atrophied because he said so many spinal
surgeries and spinal injuries.
His neck has completely fused up.
I begged Kim and Olympic gold medalist,
legit Olympic gold medalist and
wrestling broke his neck.
Yes,
for and still wants to one again,
one of the best parks.
But again,
this,
this job,
which is why,
you know,
I mean,
it's obviously,
it's a work.
Everyone's,
it's work,
it's entertainment,
but physically demanding in terms of
physically demanding crazy.
It might be more physically demanding
than a sport.
You know,
it's right up there.
The only thing I could think that might
be as bad,
but they don't do it every day is bull
riding.
I don't even know if that's a sport
that's just crazy.
People.
Pretty nutty.
I had a friend of mine who,
uh,
has done it and he had eight or nine
shoulder surgeries.
His shoulder was just shredded.
It was just,
it was just all these cut marks all over
his shoulders.
It just blown apart and they stitch it
back together and blew it apart and
stitch it back together again.
It's like,
how about stop riding fucking 2000 pound
animals,
Bro,
I don't want to fuck one of those six
are,
they're just so crazy coming out of the
gate.
You can't control that at all.
No,
you can't control that at all.
So the guys who had those runs are
pretty banged up and the other guy's
like,
I've just started,
you know,
I'm talking to a pardot to who is the
president of the NFL alumni and we've
been talking about doing something for
the guys and again,
when I do shit like that I just give it
to them just to help them.
And I've talked to a few of the players.
I got a few guys,
you know,
loving it and so it just,
again,
helping them with because there's,
you know,
those guys are all weight lifting,
running.
We can't do either now because you're so
beat up.
So it'll let you know.
It's funny when we watched,
you know,
I'm sure you watched the superbowl when
they had the 50th anniversary a couple
of years back and all the mvps that came
out there just,
it was brutal to watch how beat up they
are.
The only guy who,
of course Jerry Rice looks like he could
still play because that's a rubbish to
the greatest.
He's just a freaking super athlete and
somehow I don't know what all the crazy
shots he's been hit with that he had
survived.
But there are certain people I always
say they could eat plastic,
like they can do anything.
And um,
you know,
you said Herschel Walker prefer that.
Still wants to fight.
He was fighting in strikeforce when he's
48 years old.
I watched,
built like a fucking 20 year old freak
of nature fully shredded.
And then,
you know,
I mean,
you really have to stop and think if
that guy did fight when he was in his
twenties instead of in his forties,
late forties,
right.
He could have been a world champion and
I'm not bullshitting.
He's that kind of a freak athlete.
He,
he wasn't my claim to fame is with him,
was his
last big run for Dallas.
He caught the ball and ran 67 yards into
the ends on this is like 1997 and he put
the ball between his hands to deny
mccarter side and did the bank.
But if you didn't know because he put
the ball in there if it was battery with
doing something else.
And one of my friends,
uh,
who had a show,
a radio show into a craig in,
he had it in Arizona.
He called me up,
he goes,
D,
I'm having Walker on the show today.
He goes,
do you want to sit in the wings?
I'll ask him if he,
if he did the diamond cutter or not.
And it's called Dude,
I definitely want to hear that.
So he put me on the phone and the wings
and I'm waiting there.
And he said,
so what happened that day?
Uh,
what,
what was that thing you did with the
ball?
He goes,
well,
you know,
in the big WCW fan.
And I really liked Diamond Dallas page
and I felt like bang.
And I just did it and did a bang and
everything,
and he goes,
well,
he's on the air right now with you.
It's like,
get outta here.
And we became buddies out of it.
I lost touch with them since then,
buddy.
Guy.
Hilarious.
What I think you're doing and what I
think that one of the best benefits of
yoga,
and I'm sure the same with ddpy said
you're connecting everything together.
Whereas like yoga and sprinting,
all this explosive exercise,
it's building up the muscles,
but what you're doing is you're
tightening up all the joints.
You're tightening up the core and the
joints,
and this is the thing that people are
missing that a lot of people are missing
that are really into fitness and
exercise.
They're doing all this explosive stuff,
but what's connecting everything
together is what blows out the knees,
the ankles,
the shoulders,
the back,
and this.
This is something that's missing from a
lot of people's work because it's not as
glamorous,
right?
It's not like you do biceps.
You buys,
get all pumped up,
you do chest,
you get all pumped up,
you look great.
It's a different thing.
When you're doing is for overall body
maintenance and health and just
connecting all these parts together in a
way that makes the whole unit stronger
and healthier.
And again,
that's where I was saying I'm stretching
and strengthening.
Just think about going over your head
and reaching up what you know.
When I started class,
like I just had 175 people pay to be a
part of a workshop that I do called
inspiration meets perspiration and I
guarantee you two things.
I'm going,
I'm so jacked up,
I'm so inspired.
They're to feel like they could run
through a brick wall and two,
they're going to sweat their ass off,
but I met,
but the it where they are on whatever
level,
so the person who might be 400 pounds
and the person who shredded over there
can get a good workout at the same time
because I'm showing him how to do that
modification over there and he might
even have a chair and this guy,
I'm going to go deep.
No,
no,
go deep.
Now let me show you this.
Now grab the ball opened up and then
pull.
But before I start,
one of those things,
because there's people there who come
because they hear it yoga,
right,
right.
And I walk,
y'all got my mic on and I go,
I'm walking.
I go,
if you came here for the yoga where you
reach your arms to heaven,
sorta the universe smiles back.
You and I dropped my arms.
I go,
we won't be doing any of that shit
tonight.
What kind of Yoga did you start with?
Power Yoga was.
I was.
So he never did.
Like,
no,
I've done everything I've done.
I've done all of them at least once just
to try like I respect yoga at a
different level,
like as much as any.
Like what's really funny,
he's like guys like Brian Kest and
shipper ray and there was a,
my buddy mine,
Arthur Klein did a movie called why Yoga
and in it he gives me a camera and it
was the second time I went to Iraq and I
filmed all this shit and meet with the
guys and then go interview and I wasn't
interviewing someone else's interviewing
him for me and it got this great,
great stuff.
But in the beginning I'm talking about
how like I literally was interviewed
when I wrote the Book Yoga for regular
guys and I get it.
It was smoking hot chicks and regular
guys because back then I met TNF,
you when I said it and I never thought
women would love the workout the way
they do and those this year that you put
this together,
2005.
So I was interviewed by this guy from
the Wall Street Journal and literally he
quoted me saying when Kimberly had asked
me if I would do the yoga,
I was like fuck that I wouldn't be
caught dead doing yoga.
And he put in there after Dash Dash,
dash that I wouldn't be caught dead
doing yoga.
So that's in the beginning of the movie,
right?
So the Yogis like,
hey me.
But by the time it gets to the end where
they see like I'm just putting a
different spin on it and I'm not trying
to do what you're doing,
but similar writing as far as I'm
concerned,
more benefits.
Now,
when you say power yoga,
for people who've never done yoga
before,
differ.
Differentiate.
Like what does that mean when you say
power yoga versus something like Bikram
Yoga?
I'm being remiss to me personally,
I don't want to be that hot.
I don't want to be in a hot room.
I want to hate my body up in the cold so
I don't want to put myself in a position
where it's so hot that I can go farther
than I've ever come before because then
I'm going to walk out into the real
world and then I'm not going to get
that.
I want to be able to get what I get in
the real world and there's like,
I'm going to say I don't know how many
positions are,
I won't say there's 46 positions or
whatever it is and peegrum things.
Twenty eight,
but whatever it was,
20 slash 27 slash 20.
I can't remember.
But either way he trademarked that.
So that like a news that in court
though.
But uh,
I thought he won,
but who can either way on top of that,
I don't think it was his to begin with.
I think somebody else had had put all
those patterns together before him.
Now,
and then probably so because again,
it's freaking yoga,
it's been around for thousands of years,
but for me,
what I do like the one time Chris
Jericho and I were,
he was,
he came by my house in La when I was
living here and we went out to the park
and he's like,
so what do you do?
Do you do stand up one day,
you know,
strength building or next?
I go Chris,
I do it different every time.
I do the same open under the same
clothes,
but all the middle I go,
it's like a match man.
I'm making it up as I go along at times,
you know,
and um,
improv because I'm seeing what you can
do and then I'm going to take a
different.
I see you can really go,
well,
I'm going to push you to a different
level that I go to.
If you can't then I'm going to back way
the fuck off because I don't want to
burn you.
I want you to.
I did it with Tito.
Tito Ortiz.
One time he'd written something in a
sports illustrated,
interviewed him and I had met him at a
strip joint in Vegas and he was the man
in ufc at the time and he wanted to do,
they weren't making any money.
You remember back in the beginning when
they weren't making any money and he
wanted to go to where we were.
Right.
And I was like,
dude,
here's what I really feel.
This shit you're doing is building crazy
momentum.
I go,
we're at the top of where we're going to
go right now and it's so cyclical.
At some point it's going to fall out.
I said,
it's whole different thing than what
you're doing.
I know you appreciate it.
Which I'm super excited about,
but bottom line is,
man,
stay where you are.
And he's saying this in the SII
interview.
Right?
So I still had his number and I called
them up and he answered the phone like,
Hey,
do you know the gay?
Did he pay him?
Like,
Hey man,
I uh,
I saw what you said in,
you told the story exact cause I talked
him out of it,
like trying to go and told no stay where
you are,
dude,
you're about to have a hell of a Rut.
And he put that oversight.
I said,
man,
you remember exactly where it went?
And he said,
yeah.
He goes,
of course,
that's what was fighting again.
I heard that fight next month.
I went down and worked out once
November.
Yeah,
I worked out with them after his back
surgery.
He said a bond back,
certain files.
The first one,
the first one I've worked with them and
I'm figuring this is [inaudible] and I'm
going to fricking push him to show him
how this will strengthen them.
Then after that he wouldn't do it and I
finally pinned him down.
I go,
why didn't you do it again?
Because it was too fucking hard,
bro.
I'm like,
dude,
you say that you wouldn't have been as
fucks alive.
How could you?
And he's like,
you know,
I just thought it was too.
I said I can make it super easy and
that's where I learned pack the fog off,
meaning me,
bring it where they need it and let me
show you how we can,
not like Cain Valasquez he was just down
in,
um,
in um,
the performance center and wwe and I'm
training the guys down there.
I go down for like a week at a time.
I heard he's thinking about going into
pro wrestling after his career is over.
Well,
I'll tell you what,
man.
He was another guy was at a shitload of
back surgery and shoulder surgeries,
knee surgeries,
and he,
you know,
control huge money.
He really comes or such a natural,
as you can imagine,
a giant Mexican family.
Those are the
right,
that doesn't really exist like that.
Whatever Mexican heavyweight champion
for sports,
I watch it,
man.
He's
one of the greatest of all time,
if not the greatest.
He just,
his body couldn't keep up with his mind.
His mind was so physically tough.
I mean it's.
Mine was so he was so mentally tough.
That is his physical body would start
falling apart.
His knees,
his back shoulders.
It's just when you watch that got
trained me,
he trains like nobody,
him and Daniel Cormier,
we'll just go to a fucking war than
happy for DC.
I mean,
but he's awesome.
He's on a Thursday,
Thursday.
Please tell we've never met,
but what we do and just want the uh,
fights in Dallas this weekend.
Oh Great.
Yeah.
There's a UFC welterweight championships
in Dallas this weekend.
Awesome.
I'm going to say before you said
Cormier,
Tito Ortiz,
it was too difficult for him,
you know,
that's when you learned to back the fuck
off and that Cain Velasquez Cain.
Wow,
you're good.
You should do this.
You should.
You should have a show how much
products.
So when I,
when I was down there,
I did six workouts in full,
five d,
six work.
I do double sessions and every single
session,
every day Kaine made four of them.
And then yeah,
we changed numbers.
I sent him my program or something.
That's heart monitor and I don't know if
he's doing that.
I haven't checked back in and help him
tremendously.
Tremendously.
Really.
Would you know,
because that guy,
his whole issue is,
has been really his back.
I mean there's other injuries,
the shoulders and the knees and stuff
like that,
but they can fix those,
but then they can fix your back.
The back is.
I know if he's doing it,
lose those discs,
you know,
and I told him,
like I told you,
I said if you can get out to Atlanta,
like I'll personally work with you.
It costs you this.
I just want you to have the results
because like,
Arthur,
the results will speak for themselves.
Yeah.
No,
I mean I,
I'm a believer 100 percent and I just,
I,
I can't say enough how impressed I am
that video with Arthur and that,
that is one of the most impressive
transformation videos I think I've ever
seen online.
And that's saying a lot.
That's when I found it on the Internet.
There's few things that they really
share.
Like when Steve First did that video,
I looked at it and went,
man,
you don't have a.
back then it was still,
we were just branding it.
DDP Yoga.
You don't have DDP Yoga Dot com when it
though,
bro.
He goes,
I read a book and in the book,
remember this is 2011 and he started
read a book that talked about,
um,
if you want something go viral,
it can't be an advertising ad.
It has to be.
Unless it's super funny then that's
different you said,
but if you want,
we use two things we can do here.
We can make it an ad.
We can inspire people.
He goes,
what do you want to do?
I just let it inspired people.
So then I watched it again,
right?
And then I'm flushing it and I go,
fuck it.
I'm a Yogi in there.
So I called them up.
I go,
I don't want to be.
I mean I love Yoga,
but I don't want to go for doing your
own thing.
Right?
And he goes,
I just
want you to think about this.
And this is Steve.
Steve is like an Ivy Leaguer,
graduated from Cornell,
like super smart,
was literally on his way to being a top
guy at ibm and thought,
fuck that.
I don't want to do that.
I want to inspire people,
so he's only guy that I know is self
taught 100 percent how to edit,
how to produce,
how to do everything,
and resurrection the snake.
When you see it,
you'll know it.
That's his baby.
That video is his baby.
So he said,
just imagine this.
All right,
yoga is gonna.
Want to take credit for all of this even
though it's our shit and it's different.
It's still,
you know,
a version of.
He said that'll end up on every yoga
studio wall ever.
And that's what helped it go viral.
So remember we said that in the video
that had been turned away by [inaudible]
because he needed,
he needed the chair.
They didn't have any such thing.
They don't know how to incorporate that
into their flow.
Right.
I do see you just figured out the chair
is a balancing tool we have when we have
some more people just sitting down and
we,
we have like beginner beginner,
but by the time you come into my class,
like when I'll do,
I'll go do a class and I'll be back.
We'll let everybody know Tuesday of next
week I will be doing a class at DDP yoga
performance center.
It will be Jim and be able to fit people
in there,
but there'll be people with chairs and
there'll be people without them in.
No.
The energy will be insane because I've
got you counting and you'll see like
grabbed the ball.
Now grab a hold and work your back and
buys here and pull the breath.
Three,
two,
one.
I'm engaging everything now.
Negative rep,
so you're engaging again.
Again,
I want to get your heart rate up there
and keep it there for you.
Are pro wrestling when you were 35?
I was running nightclubs.
The nightclub business since I was 17.
They actually had any bounce.
Didn't know how old they'd know it was
an old mouth because I was six,
four and 180 pounds,
but I was tall and I started bouncing
when I was 18.
Once if I was 17 and get the hell out of
here.
You're not old enough,
but I came back when I was 18 and then I
was bar backing and bartending and I was
running.
I ran a small rock and roll joint at 22
and a half years old and then I went to
Houston.
I lived down there for awhile and Honky
tonks scene was insane.
Then I came back for a wedding and I.
There was a place in Asbury Park,
New Jersey,
which is where I'm from,
the Jersey shore.
It's really funny.
I always tell people this from this same
Jersey shore area,
me and Bambam baked lowe who is a future
whole families to meet you already be.
And Danny Devito,
Jack Nicholson,
Jon Bon Jovi,
and Bruce Bracing.
Hope from that,
like saved Jersey shore area.
But,
um,
I,
uh,
I came back for a wedding and there was
this club opening up and so I went in
there.
I talked to the guy and he goes,
well,
I need a head bartender.
I,
I'm going to be a head bartender,
but I'll be a general manager and I'll
get behind the stick two days a week.
But this place was huge.
Like you stick the bar,
get behind the bar and bartender.
No one's slower nights.
You get behind the stadium,
behind the stick.
The stick,
right?
Well,
yeah,
we'll put our place was.
It was huge.
It was a big.
We had rock and roll and disco burst
time.
Bruce springsteen ever sang dancing in
the dark was kind of with a band called
bystander and sang with them because you
know Bruce Van,
two blocks one block away was the stone
pony where I watched him probably 18
sundays in a row play with a band called
cats on a smooth surface.
You just jump up and start playing,
you know,
and now how'd you go to pro wrestling?
So I was running a club.
I tried it when I was 22.
That was right before I started to
actually,
you know,
get a chance at running a club.
I had three matches.
I sucked.
I talked,
I talked my knee and when I was 12 years
old,
I mean I was like,
I love football and hockey.
Like in my mind I'm going to play
defensive end for the New York giants.
I mean that's my mind at the time,
but then I walked back,
I hit by a car,
my face bounced off the hood,
netsuite 42 feet and appointed him
ambassador Jesus Christ.
No such thing as rehab in 1968.
So they wouldn't let me play football or
hockey.
But there,
here's the two sports that you were
broken.
They're like,
you're young,
you can't get a doctor to sign for you.
And they weren't going to sign for me.
So they gave me two choices.
Baseball and basketball.
I suck at both.
And baseball,
you're going to have somebody basketball
you don't.
And I didn't even make the team in
seventh grade and I didn't give a fuck
cause I didn't really like it.
When you say you gotTa have somebody,
what do you mean?
You have to have someone to throw the
ball back and forth with us.
You to have nine guys.
You had to know yodlee seven.
You know that the play with another
seven or whatever and I just what you
want of course,
but whatever you can do to make work for
basketball,
you just need one.
You need a ball in a hoop.
That's it.
And Eighth Grade I sat on the bench and
I'd never sat on the bench ever.
So I thought that's never happened to me
again.
And it taught me the greatest lesson.
It taught me that summer I played every
day,
all day long,
five hours a day,
minimum you when you're by yourself,
you'll lay ups,
hooks,
foul shots,
whatever you know.
And then games pickup in the beginning,
you know,
I didn't get picked up until the end
maybe.
And then as time went on over that
summer,
kept getting better and better and
better and better.
My freshman year I started and we went
undefeated.
By my sophomore year I was playing
varsity.
So I realized that work ethic equals
results.
So that was the huge lesson I learned
from that.
So now I'm 23 years old and I've,
you know,
I hurt my knee,
I and I,
and I'm going to take some time off away
from the dream of being a wrestler and I
get caught in the booze,
the poets and the party because it's so
broad
of.
And I was lucky that I had way of
parenting myself,
like getting into that whole Party
scene,
which I did,
but slowly I kind of backed myself out a
little bit each year and I've got this
club in Fort Myers,
Florida time and this one I actually own
a little piece of my buddy Tony could
pharaoh and couple other guys.
And
One night I'm in,
I'm in the office and we had a camera at
the backdoor and camera at the front
door in this place would hold legally,
probably about 600 people.
We've got a thousand in there and I'm
looking to cameras.
That person walks in,
looks just like kicked the snake
Roberts.
I'm a huge fan of Jake Roberts.
So I frigging you outside of the
building come around because I don't
want to walk through the people.
And I go to this girl judy at the front.
So I go to the guy just walked in here.
It looks like Jake Roberts.
She was,
yeah,
she goes,
I think it's him.
So I practically go running it and
they're like a huge mark.
And when I see him,
I slowed down
over fanboy go one over bad boy.
So,
uh,
well he's up at the bar and I'm like,
Hey,
uh,
you get snake Roberts.
Who wants to know
is it the guy who runs this place?
He goes,
yeah,
I go,
what are we drinking?
And that's how we started.
So it's really crazy that in
resurrection I help him not drink again.
It is amazing.
I mean this had that happening.
Then of course I paid for his drinks and
next of Ted dibiase there,
push whackers.
They are really cool.
The guy from the eighties,
if you wrestled in Tampa then you had to
go to Miami.
Well,
Fort Myers was the perfect location,
so they had seen all these different.
These boys come in through that,
right?
So I did all my own radio commercials
back then.
So back then it might be like Thursday,
Thursday hot legs.
And then I might throw in Uja ticket
thinking,
thinking.
And people didn't know if it was randy
or a hole or jessie or whoever.
And I never told anybody.
Right?
So they do this interview on
the voice because this is Fort Myers,
it's a little.
It's called a party news network.
My Buddy Kevin,
that we're going to do a spot on you on
the news network.
I'm like,
okay.
So they filmed me and my 62 pink
Cadillac.
They fill me at the studio.
Sixty two pink cadillac convertible.
It was,
yeah,
it was the board.
It was the first divorce wife I never
had.
I just saw one go by.
I eventually sold it because you're
constantly putting.
I wore.
I drove it all the time.
I love that.
That's when you supposed to keep on
convertible.
It was bad.
As bad as another bruce springsteen
song.
Dude it fucking great song.
That was.
Oh Man.
The best.
We actually at that club gave away.
It was like a 68 pink cadillac
convertible.
[inaudible] 60 to 62 pink cadillac
There's Google is probably a picture of
his.
There's a picture of me with three hot
smoking hot diamond dolls in my hallway.
It's got sober on their
fucking cars or any other pictures.
We could see the front of it.
There's a what?
A car?
No,
that's not it,
but that's,
that's like 61.
That's a hard top.
That's an old.
It's got to have the wings on the
bottom.
Go to that last one that you just went
to.
Ooh,
look at that one.
That last convertible one.
You went to one one before that.
Oh,
that's like a 56.
Crudites.
Fifty nine.
That's my favorite.
Look at that.
That's the 70,
right?
Yeah.
Seventy fucking car.
God Damn.
They made some cars.
Go,
go,
go back to that.
Did shout at me in the watchman called
there.
It's so funny because back then there is
the guide
right there.
Um,
I am 31 years old.
That is if you guys want to read a
really great,
like super detailed,
like insanely long.
Um,
it's called a letter to my younger self
players' tribune.
And so we're writing this Yo,
it's so fucking long.
I'm like,
I've let me cut back on some of drag.
No,
no.
We need more detail.
And then it goes to 9,000 words and then
they want more detail that it goes.
Look at that hair.
That's a 19 eighties head of hair.
Shit.
The cops looking at you from behind.
What the fuck?
I'm a manager that so don't let me give
you the backstory of it.
It's so my backup backup.
That's the money pitcher right there.
How will we know?
I don't know.
Fucking trouble that,
that son of a bitches major trouble.
So let me go back to where.
So I,
uh,
I do this radio spot and when they're
doing it at radio decide TB.
When I do the radio spot,
they're filming me in my car at Radio
one radio spot.
I'm wearing a wrestlemania tee shirt and
I know because I have this footage still
and I put it up on my motivational
Mondays for our very first one,
a power of power of what's possible.
And then they fill me at my office right
now.
Let me just digress the week before I'm
going around at night and I'm grabbing
the drawers,
you know,
like the,
the money tours and I'm watching video
that's upon girls.
Just wanna have fun.
Remember that with city law?
Sure.
And it had captain Lou Albanna wanted,
who's like one of my favorite managers
ever super character that a bunch of
movies.
Lou was just super freaking fun to
watch.
He's in that video and I'm picking up
the drawers and I'm not talking to
anybody but myself and I say
cap with the rubber bands and the beard.
So I look up at that video and I go rock
and wrestling.
I should've been a part of that.
And I walk into my office now,
other bartenders going to come in and
count their drawers right now.
And smoky comes into my head bartender
and he comes,
he goes,
page check.
Because my real first name is paige
Joseph Falkenberg.
And my dad said that that names ever
dry.
Anybody hates Falkenberg is get a tough
sell.
Exactly.
It might Dallas page that makes sense.
Their work,
right?
But my dad's page one and he said,
I'm freaking,
you know,
your page two.
And I'm like,
no.
As a little kid,
he said he didn't like that.
So Dallas cowboys was my theme that I
loved the most when I was little kid
don't know because of the stars or
whatever and Landry and all that shit.
And he ends up a nickname me,
dallas.
So I always loved that name.
So let's put them together.
It's kind of crazy,
right?
So I tried that as handsome.
So.
So bottom line is smokey comes in the
back and he goes,
page jake,
he goes up,
what do you mean rock and wrestling?
You should've been a part of that.
And I said,
well,
you know,
I tried it when I was a kid.
He goes,
you did,
what was your name?
I said,
handsome Dallas page.
And he went,
Oh,
you forget about using that gimmick
anymore.
And everybody laughed,
you know,
and now we're drinking sat for hours,
right?
So I can't get it out of my head.
Joe and I just start scribbling and I
write diamond Dallas page and I said,
you know,
where'd you get the diamond?
I just figured my birthday,
April.
And it just kind of float.
This is a diamond a month,
April's yeah,
April fifth is a diamond.
And I,
um,
I love classy freddy blasting and I
loved the way that name float classy,
Freddie blassie.
I thought Diamond Dallas page.
It kind of flows.
I go,
what about if my name was,
I'm too old to be a wrestler Knoxville
or try one was 22 or 21 slash 23 slash
22.
And now I'm 31.
So Yang and you,
we're going to be a manager or
something.
And what are you mad at?
Her kimmy hearts.
A manager.
I could be Diamond Dallas page,
Jimmy Hart,
you know,
it's got the heart foundation.
I could have the diamond exchange rates
shot shot.
So now we're getting pretty fucked up
and it's.
So I say,
I say,
you know,
um,
there's not a lot of really good looking
women in wrestling today.
I go,
Miss Elizabeth's beautiful.
But she's girl next door.
Beautiful.
What if I had a whole stable of ladies
and I called them diamond dolls and they
were stripper hot.
It was like,
oh,
that'll be a stretch.
Wow.
Shot,
shot,
drink,
drink.
And so the end of the night comes around
and I'm like,
Diamond Dallas page,
diamond exchange,
that diamond dolls.
I go,
man,
that's fucking be a double d bad.
And I went and I just made that up
there.
I steal that somebody.
And I just wrote it down a week later.
Here I am with the party news network
and they're interviewing me and at some
point they say,
so where does the voice come from?
Our job.
There's not a pair of white sunglasses
there at the time.
I don't know if I do it,
but they're sitting right there next to
that shit.
So I grab him when I put them on.
And let's say your sunglasses,
sunglasses,
they'll wrap out.
I mean they weren't there.
I don't know if I say out and if I go
into character,
but because I could put a mask on.
Uh Huh.
I go,
the boards comes from give me some
volume.
Give me some volume on this.
Put you in a deep breathe.
It's light that now ladies,
I wasn't talking to you.
I was talking to the ladies on TV.
He must be getting back to them and then
I'll get back to the over your data
in this interview.
You get it was good.
A little hot in here.
It would have program here like I was
saying,
because the ice man puts you in a deep
freeze.
It's like that.
Pay Attention.
Ms. Dot Bernstein.
Oh my God.
This is fucking classic.
You got a motley crue tee shirt on with
no neck.
Look at this guy.
Rock hard,
Rick,
and then Jack Bernstein has his own show
in Jersey on as a podcast or country
music,
but he's a bit.
It was a big job for a long time.
Great pipes over.
Peeling down the walls of my mind with
his bare hands.
But diamonds,
don't you know,
one of my mods.
Colab.
We had to bring in cranes.
We had to bring in trade.
We even brought in blame because we were
afraid at the bottom of that mind lay
this big,
big man.
John.
Jack.
We all bring it today.
We're bringing out fucking classics.
What years old.
This is the beginning of where we
started.
Or wait,
wait,
wait.
Look at this girl.
The Diamond Dallas baton exchange,
talking about this man is loved by women
all over the world.
They love to cuddle him.
He is the Ted Ebay.
If you wouldn't mind taking off,
take off that jacket,
that teddy bear.
Show the fans what you got.
Show them what you got here.
Board
and unbelievable man here.
This ain't no normal midget wrestler.
The world.
You know what I'm talking about?
Oh my God.
Awesome.
Russell there.
Dallas,
and those ladies are unbelievable.
They can't
listen.
Listen,
listen,
listen for Teddy,
teddy bear.
Do you have anything to add to this?
Oh my God.
This is 1987.
I'm fresh out of high school.
That's two years out of high school for
me.
So what happened was I do this promo
where they got the shelf,
like we just went ahead of it.
Okay.
So where I'm doing the news network and
they say,
where does the voice come from?
I looked out and I always say,
just don't think it,
ink it,
write it down.
It's right in front of me.
This is your spot.
I grabbed those sunglasses.
I put them on and I go,
the voice comes from Diamond Dallas page
data.
I was born to be able to touch the rest
of it's big.
It's bad.
It's an internet.
Normal genes voice and I took them off
and I kept talking.
I radio jock who is a.
It was a great fighter.
Name was smitty and Smitty sees this,
so this is like a week later,
right?
I get a phone call from the girl at the
front desk says on page on Thursday
someone to call for Diamond Dallas page.
I pick up the phone and go,
fuck you smoky.
And I hang up the phone,
right,
because I think it's smoky ribbing me
right?
Calls back.
She goes,
it's not.
Smokey is named Smith.
He's got a radio show.
He wants to talk to you.
I go,
hello?
He's like,
yeah,
I want to bring you on the show.
He goes,
know I'm a boxer who has his own show
about boxing,
but I want to start doing wrestling.
I go,
he goes,
I want to have you on the show.
I go brow,
I don't really do it.
I was just making that shit up,
you know,
and he's like,
who cares?
It's radio and I'm like,
man,
I don't know.
He goes,
I'm going to have captain blue while
banner worn.
Like,
what's the odds of that?
I'm going to have captain Lou Albano on
the show.
I want you to be my cohost.
I go,
do I get the talk?
The captain will.
He's like,
absolutely.
I go,
oh man.
So I do that show when I do another one
with sergeant and he says to me,
he says,
you know,
you got to do something with this
Diamond Dallas page thing.
You're a natural.
I go,
many do what?
I don't know what the fuck to do.
I mean it's just something in my head.
And he says,
I got this friend of mine named Rob
[inaudible] who is a boxing promoter who
now is working for the awa up in
Minnesota.
I'll give you his address,
send them a tape or something.
So I think about it and I write those
storylines for those guys and then I
make that tape and I sent it to the Awa.
No bullshit.
Joe.
Two weeks later I get a phone call,
hey,
um,
is this Diamond Dallas page?
And I'm like,
uh,
yeah,
this is rob [inaudible] from the Awa.
We've seen your tape.
We want to bring you and your boys and
for a tryout,
he goes,
probably cut one question,
you know,
we've shown them tape around and
everybody kind of liked your stick,
you know,
it's fresh,
got energy.
Said,
but what's ever heard of you?
Where are you guys working?
Well Rob,
we've got one problem.
I'm,
none of those guys can.
He's like,
what?
He goes,
why would you send us a tape?
I go,
it's like a secret society.
Like no one could figure out how to
fucking get in so you know why they're
trading.
I could manage.
And I'm like,
God,
don't call us.
We'll call you.
And two weeks later,
God just alignness for me at some for
some reason just to be where I am today.
But Paul Heyman,
who's one of the biggest stars,
as you know,
a character on Bebee,
whl television was called Poli
dangerously at the time he left the aws,
went to the end two a which was going to
get bought by Ted Turner.
Let the huge spot open for a young guy
that could talk.
They brought me in.
All those clothes you saw me in.
I was wearing that shit in Fort Myers,
Florida.
And I said to my buddy,
curt church,
who was my head bouncer at a time I the
floor and I and when this was starting
to happen,
and I go,
dude,
can you imagine if I ever have a reason
to dress like this?
And if anything I got way more tapered
down.
I wasn't living the gimmick but a bear.
That was the beginning of everything.
And then dusty Rhodes had come into
Florida for Florida championship
wrestling.
Dusty took me under his wing man and he
gave me every break that ever meant
anything to my career early on.
That's why was so important for me to be
there for cody because I get choked up
just thinking about it without dusty
Rhodes original Diamond Dallas page.
He gave me every break I ever had and
for me to watch his son do what they did
last weekend.
Do you remember your first match?
My first,
my first match a was a tag match,
so I'm managing now.
Okay.
Three and a half years.
And then I finally get the call because
dusty who went to wwe and he did just
polka dotted gimmick.
Willem,
he came back to run the to WCW and now
he's Nwa world champion.
He's one of the smartest guys ever in
our business.
And um,
I developed a relationship that was
super tight with him when we were in
Florida,
but it was his wife Michelle,
who really kept it going when he wasn't.
Because when I'd call up just to check
in with dusty,
once in a while she'd say,
don't worry Dallas dusty.
We'll call you back.
And knowing how bad he is at calling
someone back.
I know that that's why I think Michelle
and my whole fame speech,
because I know without her,
I don't know if it ever would have kept
going the way it today,
but dusty,
you know,
he brought me in and I managed the
freebirds Michael ps Hayes and Jimmy Gam
Garland,
which was such an education,
such a good time.
Michael's still one of my best friends
today and I hope Scott Hall,
who was big Scott Hall come in,
changed his entire look from blonde hair
and a big role as mustache.
Adam dye his hair jet black and give
them this brush cut beard that like
nobody had the 5:00 shadow and no one
knew the fuck he was and I brought them
in.
And what is happening as you see all the
crazy clothes I wore.
Well,
five months in magnum ta who's get dusty
righthand man comes up to me and he's
like,
listen,
we're going to keep you at the color
commentator spock's.
I'm also doing color commentating with
our pitch off who would later run the
company.
Um,
and he said,
um,
he said,
we can't let you manage anymore.
Like what?
What I do wrong?
He goes,
it's not,
it's not anything you're doing wrong,
bro.
He goes,
he goes,
it is with the hair and the wrap and the
dowels and those crazy clothes.
He goes,
you're taking too much attention away
from the boys and they're the ones who
draw the money.
And I was like,
so fuck.
Are you telling me magnum,
that I'm too over the top or wrestling?
And he goes,
as a manager Kinda.
He said,
but you know,
what we should have done is put you in a
pair of tights and boots and see if you
could do this shit.
I had seven months left on my contract,
Bro.
I said,
fuck this.
I never got in this business to be a
manager.
I wanted to live the dream.
Well I'm going to do it.
And I went down there and they beat the
fuck out of me.
Now.
Did they teach you how to do it first?
No,
they.
What they do is they blow you up.
Mrs Was not done.
The nxts is different.
I'm like down there performance center,
but the original power plant,
my one of my mentors,
a guy named Jody Hamilton who was the
assassin and he really taught me a lot
and so did this Guy Sarge,
but in the beginning they want to run
you off so they want to see if you'll
quit.
Oh,
absolutely.
It's just get you to quit.
It's a different level of seal training,
like you're going to do 50,
50 Hindu squats where you're asked to,
you know a and up again,
and then you can do 10 pushups and then
you're going to do $50 and then 10 and
50 and 10.
By the time you get to that third 50
your life,
you're not in shape.
You're screwed because we're going to
500.
Yeah.
Fit Hindu squats are a big thing amongst
wrestlers,
right?
Yep.
It's a great way to get in shape.
It's really wears on your knees and
boom,
boom foot.
It's really good for you.
Nice and non.
No,
no,
not free.
If you've got bad and you're wondering
where to go,
you got great knees.
Inputs.
It's like anything.
There's only so many bumps.
You're allowed life.
The MS was on fear factor back in the
day.
To this day,
I say he's the fittest guy that was ever
on the show.
That fucking kid is a stud.
He is a stud.
He did this stunt in cold water where
you had a dive into this cold water,
hold your breath in and complete this
stunt,
and he was in it for more than two
minutes holding his breath and cold
water enough,
you know,
anything about cold water that is
unbelievably impressive.
Plus very grueling physical activity.
It's not.
He was just in cold water holding his
breath for two minutes,
which is impressive enough as it is,
but he was swimming around and pulling
off like he blew everybody out of the
water
and he told me he did a shitload of
those.
He was doing $500 a day.
Five hundred Hindu squad kid,
no kid,
and that's why it was that guy shape.
Let me give you a super nice guy too.
Tremendous.
I love them is I think he's going to be
a huge superstar.
He's already a huge superstar in
wrestling,
but I think he's going to be huge
superstar in the acting transcend.
So let me tell you the first time I meet
him.
I'm here in La.
I'm living in Playa Vista.
Before that,
all that shit blew up there.
Right.
I'm living there.
It's night.
Yeah.
I want to say it's 2004 because I'm
gonna I,
I wrestled until I was 46.
Then I took off two and a half years.
Came here,
did the whole acting thing and put my
dues and put the work in.
Now I want to go back and I want to show
people what I can do with my ddpy
program at 49,
so I call up a buddy of mine named Rick
bassman and he's got the upw at the time
when he's got the own area,
kind of like,
like the power plant was and then kids
are training their.
Whenever I said,
do me a favor,
send me over one of your boys and let
him a combine.
Get me and you know,
I'll do what I want to do and then I'll
help work with him.
A little bit and so he sends me Mike,
the Miz and just the sweetest kid and
we,
we have a great talk on the way over
there and you know,
I get,
I get done doing all my shit,
you know,
and then I said,
okay,
what do you want learn?
He's like,
you're gonna work with me.
I'm like,
hell yeah,
I want to work with you.
Got great attitude,
dude,
of course going to work with you.
And we worked and now he's taking me
home and he tells me about how he's was
a real world.
He's like the original real world guy.
So he's like,
I said,
man,
you've got that piece.
Like people already know you.
That's,
that's,
that's really worth something.
It will really come back to help you
later as you're going through this.
So we get all the way back to my place
and I'm like,
you want to come in for a beer?
He's like,
oh,
absolutely.
So he comes in and who's on the porch?
But stone cold.
Steve Austin,
who I live with at a time and Kevin Nash
are there.
So he's like in,
Whoa,
what the fuck,
I was just a Wrestlemania a full two
years ago and you know,
when I was inducted in the hall of fame
and Ms Dot was back doing one of his
things.
Now he's got the,
the reality show with his wife,
which is super funny,
and there's times where I'm like,
this is really real because your reality
show,
there's no such thing as real life in
reality show shit,
but there's a lot of their stuff you
could tell that they're like shooting on
because they want the real,
uh,
the real deal.
But he told that story like he was
backstage,
but it's one of his suits on and his
wife there he goes,
Whoa,
I come here and database Kabir let,
let's talk about the story when we first
met.
And I just knew that that kid,
like he's hit a couple of roadblocks
along the way that he could,
he could have quit.
He could've walked away from it.
He could have not.
But he had such a belief in himself.
I always tell people,
never underestimate the power you give
yourself by believing in you.
And that's who the MS is and I think
he's going to be a huge.
I love the fact we get a of different
slat now because of the man.
The Rock,
the biggest star in the world is one of
us.
And did you see blockers would Sina?
No.
Oh Dude,
watch it.
It's one of the funniest movies I've
ever seen and I was flying home.
I'm telling my wife,
you got to watch this movie.
It's hysterical.
She's sitting next to me and I'm not
even walk.
I can't hear it because I've already
seen it.
She's laughing so hard,
but I'm laughing because I'm watching it
and I know what they're saying or an
idea of it.
But when you got visual comedy,
which you know,
when you don't hear the words and you're
watching like buster Keaton and you're
laughing,
that's really good shit.
And it's super funny and seen it killed
it.
So you know,
he's,
he's super alias actor now.
He just did Ferdinand moving him.
I mean he's on fire.
I,
last time I saw him at the show,
I just pulled them over for a second.
I just because I don't really know him
that well,
but I wanted to know.
I wanted him to know that I was so proud
of him not for what he's done is an
actor,
even though I'm super proud of him on
that level,
but how he carried the company on his
back for over a decade and still did so
much work for charity mean it was mind
boggling.
Like no one has done more along that
whole make a wish thing than Ciena has.
But when I saw.
Did you see him when he hosted the sps?
No,
dude,
you're a comedian.
You know how hard that shit is.
He is not extended up comedian,
but he was frigging amazing what he's
been acting for so long now.
It's so loose and you know,
this is the thing about being behind the
mic on the wwe as well.
Just being able to do that in front of
all those apps that.
Absolutely.
I'd say that's its own level of like
sometime 20 minute promos are doing.
The Rock confuses me in like how much
energy is.
I don't know how the fuck he can do all
the things he does.
Yeah.
He's always doing something like,
I go to his instagram page all the time,
like a lazy.
He's.
He flies into China.
It's four in the morning.
He's lifting weights.
Like what the fuck man?
The hardest word in cat I have ever seen
this old way of doing something.
Yeah,
I mean he's just sandwiches everything
together.
I don't know how the fuck he does it.
I'll tell you,
Jericho is.
I put like guys like who have the most
insane work ethic right now?
Rock is way past everybody who's past.
Anyone I've ever seen that.
Me Too.
And,
and I'll just occasionally put,
you know,
just a tweet out,
just says,
hey dude,
keep up the great work.
He's one of those guys where I go,
how long can a human,
how long can the human body.
I'm like going like this because you
know,
he's only sleeping four hours a night.
He's got to.
Yeah.
I think he's kind of like my buddy
Steve.
You,
they don't need to sleep.
They just keep going.
Jericho's the same way.
Jericho,
when he's not wrestling,
he's singing when he's not doing that,
he's doing his podcast so he's not doing
that.
He's doing this or he's doing that or
we're doing this,
we're doing that and like he flew in,
they frigging private jet him into the
Olin deal and I didn't even know.
I don't like to know.
I want to be surprised
and they shot this angle with Kenny
Omega,
who's one of the premier superstars that
our business right now,
and they did him in Jericho at 47,
sold out the Tokyo dome.
Forty 7,000 people in January.
His match,
these wrestled for Dan Churches.
Everything.
We're 48 minutes.
They wrestled for 37 minutes.
He's 47.
Well,
he jumped on a plane while he's touring.
They flew him in.
You put a mask on,
you thought it was one guy.
He pulls the mask off.
Vettery drops Omega and bought a boom.
It's Jericho.
The place goes bat shit crazy.
He gets out,
grabs his deal,
hopped on a plane and flies were
supposed to play at 12:00 that night.
That's Jericho.
And the other guys Patista.
So Battista Yo.
Between a galaxy,
right?
I mean the,
here's four guys that are like red hot
as actors and they're all the boys.
He's fantastic and Guardians and oh my
God,
he's so good at being self deprecating
Dorky.
I mean he plays like a goof so well and
he's such a cool dude.
Man.
Tony was here right now.
He would be [inaudible] and his pants.
He really wouldn't be able to hold it
together.
Turn to that.
Now what's.
What's interesting is that this group,
I mean Hulk Hogan was probably one of
the first big guys that transcend into
moodle.
Yes,
yes.
But he got turned off by Hollywood.
He had apparently it got a couple of
Dick robbers.
I don't know,
that's a real story,
but I'll tell you what he said,
of all the guys that I know,
like I'm super supportive whole because
he was super supportive of me too.
Great Guy.
Oh Man.
You know,
and,
and he right now he's doing.
He finally got back and they finally
brought them back in ww,
which I was super excited about because
to me going into the whole thing without
hope being in there,
just kind of like,
Whoa,
video of me interviewing Hulk Hogan for
Spike TV.
I got a chance to interview him for
Spike TV back in the day when he was a
spike TV.
Went into the wrestling business.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
I hope that I helped them do that
because I was one of the names that
brought.
Yeah,
that's what I was wrestling.
So for me as a kid,
I mean I was a giant fan of Jimmy
superfly,
snuck a Bob Backlund,
although when I was in high school and
early eighties and Hulk Hogan.
So for me to get a chance to interview
Hulk Hogan,
it was this one of the greatest
professional wrestlers
all time.
Sports and entertainment,
huge personality.
The one and only Hulk Hogan.
We share a brother,
you know,
to be here with Joe Mania.
It doesn't get any better than this
brother.
These guys are going to war out here.
It's unbelievable that you've made as an
mma fights before you a UFC fan.
I'm a huge fan.
My brother.
Now I understand that you have recently
announced a partnership with TNA
wrestling and it's president Dixie
Carter,
and you're going to be moving to spike
TV.
We're going to see some Hulkamania on
Spike TV.
Tell us more about that.
Well,
you know brother tonight I got a ton of
energy and our partners with spike.
I'm partners with Dixie Carter.
I'm partners with t and a and we just
got the green right brother on January
fourth to get a impact.
We're going wide open.
We're going to head on head.
We're going to battle wwe Monday night
of January,
Fourth Hulk Hogan and TNA.
We're coming after everybody burst out
for everybody's.
Now I understand that you have you
recently released a book,
if you've done a wrestling tour in
Australia,
when are we going to see Hulk Hogan
Wrestle in Tna?
Well,
brother,
I'm going January.
Fourth luck.
I said Monday night we're going to war.
TNA impacts,
but you'd never know.
I'm going over there to take over.
The maniacs are coming,
all the TNA star's going to be there and
you never know when the old man with a
yellow boots might just step in that
ring.
Brother Hulk Hogan is coming back.
Lazy Gentlemen,
CCNA wrestling live on spike TV.
Hugs here for the fights.
You know you want to watch them on TV.
Watch.
You're going to do brother in the UFC
runs wild on you.
What are you going to do?
That's the good question.
Thank you very much.
Would spot brother.
I was so happy you ever met Jean
Oakland.
Oh Man.
What did they skies on the planet,
but the whole coming when I got to do
much stuff with him because we not only
did the malone stuff mean morale.
I mean my wound against Rodman and
Hogan,
but the next month they come in and
because we shot that angle on the
tonight show and the next month they go
in,
Hogan ambitious off and they runj off
the set.
I come in from the wings,
not on his ass and it's me and Jay Leno
gets
bitch off.
Flip them over.
Look at.
Hold on,
my God,
that is hilarious.
Oh,
that is so funny.
Jay Leno was holding the dog down and he
grabs his hair is crazy.
This is so ridiculous.
Oh God.
It was,
you know,
it was so much fun.
I'll tell you,
you know another guy,
I mean,
he came and worked out with us and he
didn't,
didn't spend as much time like malone
because malone was like a super athlete,
but he works out at all now.
Just turns wrenches,
gotta learn you gotTa.
Learn how to move around a little bit
and know we just worked around in,
in hope was never that guy to lay stuff
out.
Like today,
a lot of this stuff is laid out,
you know,
back then it was like you called as you
go and,
and so I was a guy who actually did
that.
I could lay everything out and that's
how I liked to know where we're going
and I'm still going to talk you the
whole time,
you know,
but you know,
bottom line is a Yo jake,
just working them through it and it was
a lot of fun when Hulk Hogan was in
rocky three.
I mean,
that was,
you was fucking fantastic.
And then you also get to see God damn
big.
He is.
Salon is go,
whoa.
When he picked sly up by his neck and
you're like,
Holy Shit.
And then you know,
when they go through the whole thing,
when afterwards,
you know,
hoke is like smiling and laughing with
them and still only like,
oh good.
You know,
rocky was like,
oh,
all right,
like a little rough out.
That's what it is,
brother.
One of the greatest moments of great
moment in film.
So awesome.
I mean it was said that that was a big
moment in film too for a lot of people
that thought like pro wrestling is fake,
right?
It's like,
well,
ain't nothing fake about that.
I mean,
it's entertainment,
but if you don't think that's
[inaudible] difficult to do,
like look at the size difference.
Jesus,
million bucks,
they're dead.
It looked fantastic.
He was just super good to me and what he
picks him up over his head.
Is there a video in this?
See if you can find video of it because
when Paul is going crazy and he's having
a heart attack or I love that.
Oh my God,
that was a great fucking scene.
You know what I love about slide?
He's the perfect example.
Everybody counted them out and he's
fucking stronger.
Never again.
You know?
He's like,
Yo,
we're going to move around a little bit.
Come on to hit you a little bit,
a little bit with this
little hole mania music.
They're just fucking.
That was snug.
Stallone was so slim and trim back
though,
right?
It's kind of hilarious that he was
playing a heavyweight champion because
he's not a big guy.
He really is more like a middleweight,
but Hogan was.
I mean he wouldn't even be able to back
in these days.
Wouldn't you be able to make the UFC?
Is Weight limit UFC as a 265 pound
cutoff for whatever reason?
Really?
Yeah.
There's A.
There's no super heavyweight division
in.
MMM.
Yeah.
There.
There was a super heavyweight division.
It's possible,
but the UFC is never implemented it,
so it's been sanctioned.
There's a 265 and above,
but the UFC heavyweight division has a
cutoff and the bunch of guys have had to
cut weight.
Brock's a big example.
Brock had to cut weight to make to 65,
Francis and gone.
Oh Tim.
Silvia.
Few guys have had to actually cut.
Wait,
Mark Hunt,
cut weight to make to 65 work.
Mark's about walking around in tank
five,
10 to 90.
Just bad.
Bad.
He's a bad man mark on.
But I love about sly.
Like you know,
you go back to it.
A lot of people don't know that story.
I'm sure you do.
You know how he wrote that script or
rocking would not sell it and you get
all 300 like Ryan O'neal to play rock.
You're someone called Paul Newman.
I forget who it was.
I feel,
I feel like it was Ryan O'neil,
they wanted Ryan o'neal to play rocky
and he held out and he's like,
no,
I fucking wrote this.
This is me your vehicle.
And that's it.
That's the greatest example of being
positively unstoppable in owning it.
Like just alone could have written this
book or has 100,000 times and when you
know,
like he,
he's,
he's one of my mentors without me
knowing him,
you know,
because I've just watched how he's lived
his life and he's recreated themselves
so many times and that's what I'm
constantly trying to crazies of the guys
doing the expendables as a fucking
action star.
He's in his seven deans.
Crazy fuck in their seventies is
believable in inaction is guys have like
beat people up and movies like a
suspension of disbelief.
I'll let it slide,
but when you see him doing it,
you're like,
I kind of believe it.
The guy's still jacked at 70,
72,
I think 73 years old.
Whatever the fuck he is.
How old is he now?
Seventy two years old.
That's fucking insane.
Let me give you a behind the scenes from
stone cold Steve Austin,
who was like a brother to me,
like a real one,
like literally we lived together.
We wrote together,
uh,
one of my best friends and he's doing
the first expendables and he's doing,
we talk about,
I guess he's on the set for about a
couple of weeks by this time and he
says,
I'll tell you what day.
And you remember every top Alpha dog is
in that first movie because he grabbed
the,
you know,
the heavies of the heavies.
The guys who had the biggest names and
uh,
Austin said in a world of Alpha dogs,
there is one number one guy and his name
is so bester stolen.
And he said,
when he were doing the Hollywood fight
in the back,
stallone was like,
come on,
bring it,
like meant it.
He broke his fucking,
broke his neck.
Have you seen his neck?
But they did an x ray of his neck.
He's got these fucking screws keeping
his spine together in his neck.
He showed it on,
it was the shell or Letterman,
but he was on and they showed an x ray
of his neck.
He broke his fucking neck during that
movie because he's 68 at the time,
69.
And he's getting thrown into a wall.
Right.
And,
and telling Austin who's a tough son of
a giant ring,
it wants it to be real.
I mean,
he is.
look,
he got knocked out by Antonio carver.
Oh,
Antonio Tarver in one of those rocky
movies,
right?
Right.
I mean,
I think he was deep into his sixties and
he got fucking knocked out there doing
the boxing scenes where they're going
over things and tarver cracked him.
I would kill to do a workout with him
and show him because he.
Oh no one works out harder neck,
so I'll fucking fused together that
plates.
The bionic man.
Look at that.
That's fucking crazy.
So he's got three discs fused together.
He might be the toughest guy.
Pound for pound,
age for age alive.
What's a four months ago?
This is him.
Four months of the word.
God.
Who was the other guy there?
Take your sunglasses off bro.
Look at Jack.
D is 72 crazy man.
I love the Guy Man.
I mean you want to feel good to sit down
and watch a rocky movie.
I interviewed him.
Him Too.
He's a super nice
guy and like real,
like self deprecating,
loose laugh doesn't take himself
seriously at all.
No Ego.
Just joking around.
Easy to like somebody heckled out.
He's like,
oh your mom.
Really funny.
Funny Guy.
Real real nice guy to know.
But listen man,
I'm,
I don't know what else we could talk
about,
but I think what you're doing is fucking
awesome.
I'm super pumped that we finally got
together.
I would love to do a workout with you
for sure.
Absolutely.
And what about,
what about tomorrow?
What time?
Tomorrow?
I'm here.
I'm leaving.
I'm leaving on Thursday afternoon.
So I have.
Let's figure this out after.
The one thing I want to do about this.
Let me tell you about the positively
unstoppable.
When to come out.
The Art of owning it doesn't come out
until January,
but I,
here's my goal.
Okay.
I had two books before this.
I didn't push them to be best sellers
because they weren't really worthy.
This is because I know it's going to
really help people and here's the hook
that I want to do.
Reason why I want people to get it,
preorder it now,
and this is what I want to give with
this anyone and it's up on my site.
If you go to DDP yoga.com/positively
unstoppable,
and you ordered the book there,
there'll be an address right there.
The DDP Yoga performance center,
which is one,
two,
three,
nine concord road,
Smyrna,
Georgia,
three zero,
zero,
eight zero.
If you send me a self addressed stamped
envelope,
we've got these book plates,
that Random House or random house book
and they send me these book plates that
I'm going to sign and if you send me
that self addressed stamped envelope
with a proof that you purchased the book
that you preorder the book,
I'm going to send you my autograph.
Well autographed from the book when I'm
doing a comicon,
I'm $40 for a picture.
$40 for an autograph,
Sixty Dollars Combo.
The book costs 24 99.
So if you're looking to get a DDP,
each signature diamond Dallas page
signature,
you got it for the book.
I will send it to you.
My goal is to make positively
unstoppable.
A best selling book and I think it might
easiest,
easiest.
The only way I'm really going to do it
is by preorder because I don't have any
machine behind me except for my own
shit,
you know,
and doing this the way I just want to
check one thing.
It was sort of look at you and where's
the,
what's the APP?
How can people find the APP?
The APP is at DDP Yoga Dot com,
like it's up on itunes and droid and if
they're looking for it on itunes or
google marketplace,
but if it's,
if it's on itunes or Android,
all it's going to cost more because you
know,
they charge more,
they tack on 30 percent.
So you can download the APP from your
website.
You go to Dallas,
you go to Diamond Dallas page.com and
you will be able to um,
get the APP right there.
And Right now I'm doing 20 percent off
work though.
Don't you have to go to the APP,
sort of put an APP on your phone?
I'm not really actually.
Sure
exactly.
Sure how that works,
but I just know if you're going to DDP
yoga.com,
it's going to be cheaper and then you
got to get.
You get.
You can prep for a month,
three months,
a year,
whatever the deal.
We'll figure it out.
The one thing I do want to mention to
you is,
and maybe we can come back when this
gets released and talk about this,
but I've got a new documentary coming
out.
You've already seen and I know you're
going to love the resurrection.
Jake the snake,
if you want to see that.
We just took it off Netflix.
It's only on itunes.
It's like ninety nine cents.
It's absolutely the look up to inspire.
You know,
everyone has some sort of addiction in
their life,
whether it's their uncle,
their father,
their sister or brother.
There's somewhere around it.
I've had so many people come up to me in
so many people have come up to Jake and
say,
that movie changed my life.
People say I'm three months sober,
I am two years sober.
Like that movie changed my life and Jake
doing the program,
it gave him a way to get wins,
meaning like going from 300,
seven pounds to under 302 to 78 and you
know,
and so forth.
But being able to move more and be able
to feel better.
So resurrection gives you that
inspiration and you just watched
Arthur's video.
Well,
Jake's movie The resurrection snake,
you're gonna Laugh,
you're gonna cry.
Most of all you're going to be inspired.
So the new documentary we are coming out
will be out sometime in 2019.
We'll,
I'll talk to you before it comes out and
it's called relentless and it goes from
the day that Kevin Nash blows my back
out and have gag set.
He didn't do it.
It was my body was finally brought.
He's always trying to protect me and
vice versa.
But when I blew my back out to where we
are today,
we have actually take out the wrestling
shit.
We have 16 years of footage of this
entire journey up and down and up and
down and how we became with the program
at eight year overnight success,
and this is one of the most inspiring
movies I know anybody will ever see now.
It'll be out this year.
And um,
that's really it.
You know the APP is that DDP Yoga Dot
com.
If you want to get the book,
if you want a presale,
go to DDP yoga.com/positively
unstoppable.
And like I say,
I'll love to send you a copy twitter to
Muslim video for Arthur on twitter too
because it's fucking fantastic.
Thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
Glad we finally did this.
Awesome.
Bye everybody.
I had to Piss so bad.